hello
yo yo
i think we're live
everything looks to be in order
yo what up everybody
we are live
for the final
day
of our 100 completionist run of elden
ring
all the quest lines
and all of the bosses
the final day i have no idea how long
this is going to take
this could take two hours
this could take
all day
i have no idea but
all i know is we're gonna finish today
we're gonna do it all of it
yes all hail rick
break it rick has actually made it to
the end game i honestly didn't think
that we would make it this far
with this
insanely stupid build
it's actually been a lot of fun
all hail rick
okay
so i have our list ready to go
the list is up
yesterday we completely finished caled
and lay in dell along with all of our
quest lines pretty much
i also have the elden ring wiki ready to
go just in case you guys cannot explain
where the hell somebody is
but i am going to try and do everything
based on what you guys tell me in the
chat because
i think it's funny that's the main
main reason we're doing that
no we never would have made it with 12
vigor i'm glad we didn't do that but
yes
how did rick prepare for this amazing
day
for this momentous day
well
we're here rick doesn't need to prepare
rick is always
prepared at all times
preparation
is not needed for rick he's always ready
all right
let's pull up the list where do you guys
want to start because we got we got to
get going we got to go go
go
we have a lot to do in altus plateau
mountain a little bit in the
mountaintops we gotta go to lake a rot
and kill that dragon
dragonkin
uh couple
the consecrated snow fields i might
start there because i know where this
this is
i'm gonna start there
and work our way back
let's go there first
yeah yeah
i think that's so this is the town it
would be i need to get the map for this
area too
do you think miyazaki writes some parts
of the story thinking this actually
makes no sense but i like to see people
try to find meaning in that a hundred
percent absolutely does
we finished the entire flame frenzy
quest line
i'm pretty sure we've done every quest
line
uh up to this point
good morning kyle how are you
good morning everybody
started the lower level areas
and
you know how i am i'm very random
aren't i
i just kind of go around probably in the
most
inefficient way possible
let's screw it we're having fun
am i too far
i think it's this way
because this
it is kind of a fun achievement i just
wanted to learn everything about the
game that i possibly can
and i thought to myself might as well
stream it right
might as well stream it
are you going to kill the bot invaders i
mean it's not a boss so we don't have to
do it
so now
it's over here isn't it
it has been a great ride
a great ride indeed
nah this ain't it
what is that
little flame of frenzy action over here
i'm surprised they're attacking me since
i am the lord of chaos well i'm not the
lord of chaos yet
but i have it within me
what's gonna happen next
we gotta we got a lot of ideas man
there's no shortage of content
there is a mod that i've seen that makes
every enemy in the game melania
every single thing even the goats are
melania
i thought that would be hilarious
but we'll see
every single one
here we go this is what we want
don't do that hey you never know
could be fun
it was too crazy i imagine it wouldn't
we would do that for one day and then it
would be like yeah this is not possible
if they add dlc what do you want it to
be
uh anything i'll take anything at this
point any any dlc i will be happy i
don't care what it is
yeah after that you should yeah solo her
no problem
hey technically i did that right i did
solo her
took a lot of attempts
it took a lot of attempts for let me
solo her at the beginning as well
yeah i think randomizer mod could be
really fun too
and just try to like beat the game
maybe not try to do everything
could be fun there's there's no shortage
of content here
no shortage
i don't know why i'm picking anything up
i don't need anything anymore
yes i do pull i do think that
streamer i watch that does insane
challenges like completing the game
using only items you can buy from
merchants or shields only
that's pretty cool i just don't see
myself as like one of those people
though
and actually trying to complete it i do
think of myself as a goofball
who will try
but it won't go well
i lock on you please thanks
howie the hook
cause i am a bit of a goofball if you
haven't noticed
easy peasy lamb and squeezy
you get a lot from this area like what
are these smithing stone eights
why do we need so many is this another
one
somber nine holy [ __ ]
that was just a regular smithing stone
okay i like that
yeah i'm a bit goofy and it's so weird
that i'm like a lore guy
i'm a lore guy but i'm a goofball like
does that make any sense not at all but
i think it's different
so i'm gonna roll with it
all right where are you
stars of darkness
yeah this one is darker than the other
one
actually
what
oh that's the worst attack that could
have happened
i'm dead
really
yeah what's the difference between this
one and the other one
kind of let me hit his face
but i might get something there
oh you like those dodges though
i mean
there we go
horny tray
i can't get the stabby
can't get the stabby boy
the orange things are dragon balls they
kind of do look like dragon balls
actually
oh i almost got it
[Music]
oh
run run run
good [ __ ] good [ __ ]
never seen this
holy [ __ ]
that is terrifying
never seen that attack
all right so we're just spamming me now
huh
[Music]
wrench
you can't hit me
[Music]
all right that was way harder than i
thought it would be but we did it
dude those attacks are awesome
okay here we go
play the randomizer mod right now
yeah let me just stop everything we're
doing to do the randomizer mod right now
the [ __ ]
no
banana uh oh
okay we're good sorry
mark it off
i'm gonna stay organized today so that
was
stars of darkness where is the uh putrid
grave warden duelist
where that
turned out like i was forcing that video
yesterday i don't know what you're
talking about but
all good
um
i summoned two people they both died
then i used the dung eater puppet and we
beat
eat them nice
the dung eater puppet huh here let me go
spend these runes
the boss in the catacombs apparently
it's in this area so
i don't know if that's
in some catacombs found behind the lock
door
in this in the catacombs
okay where that where's that
a little bit of strength
a little bit of strength
let me go uh get this as well
a bosch boss rush mod i have no idea i
don't know who's working on stuff it
seems like people are making mods like
all the time
yoda don't joke about that come on dude
it's not that big of a deal
any
got our map
let's see
i'm being attacked by a wolf right now i
don't know where the catacombs are here
or
was that where i was
i don't remember
i don't know is it back at the beginning
oh i got invaded
can't take a shower without y'all acting
up
ah they're fine
[Music]
oh that's grinch
when did you get these powers
saw you
[Music]
i don't really like melania's great rune
at least for this build
i might go back to radon
almost died to that
i think it affects my overall health as
well
she just powered through that huh man
frozen outskirts area
bro really
frozen outskirts
um
is there any marking
it makes your flask less effective yeah
i don't want to use that then let me go
back here
we don't really need much much more king
i just haven't come across them
as much as usual
reduces the effectiveness of your glass
okay
well let's go back to radon
cuz that was doing us good
but yeah i don't know
it is it in here is that is this what
you mean by the catacombs because this
seems like a dungeon
there's like another area
like to the left over there
ah audio why oh creative cloud hey i
gotta update my [ __ ] creative cloud
so it's gonna destroy my computer that's
really cool dude
what's over here then it's out of
curiosity
ah
got it
see when you guys tell me things like
waterfall ravine i don't know where that
is i have no
idea i don't know how you all memorize
names of areas
of specific areas
is where don's less effective than
morgot's rune i mean it depends on what
you want because it does
different things
okay
let's see
there's invisible paths back there off
the side yeah i know i want to go and
find this boss though
oh death root
is there a death root back there
because we need to do that too
started eldering a few days ago it's
been so much fun might start recording
some of it any tips and builds anything
like that nope just do whatever whatever
your heart desires man it all works
down and to the right
i mean i can't go down i'm literally at
the be at the beginning
okay i'll just hang left
excuse me right
welcome you're never late you can't be
late to a live stream at silly gooses
y'all get here when you get here
i can't see anything around here
ha
ha idiot
is are you running with a treasure chest
yep
golden runes 13.
oh i got lost
like i just want some treasure
i'm just kind of following where these
guys are
i don't really know where i am or where
i'm going
that doesn't look quite right
oh
wait how did i end up going this way
what the
what the heck
the ban yesterday got me thinking
so you're telling me you got banned
yesterday
like
i just wonder how your brain works
oh then what are you talking about
hmm
i mean when you're banned you're banned
from everything
yay i found it
oh yeah you're you're banned you're gone
i don't want anything to do with you if
you get banned
hell yeah
of course
yeah i have a lantern
i don't think it would have helped that
much there but we got it
oh i hate you
that scared me
you can check the list in the
description
oh i might have been too late for this
wall
you fell idiot
dummy thick
okay
a lot of people accidentally get banned
by a bug in the new patch
the new patch for
youtube
[Music]
what new patch
um excuse me
okay it's killing it
all right oh
okay
they like lingered
around oh my god
i just need to ride that statue up and
get the heck out of there
this coal guy is going to keep asking if
you play d d
what's your answer no i don't play d at
all
[Music]
yeah that was quite literally worst case
scenario
oh that's still down okay it's lit
dungeons and dragons
but people weren't actually banned the
game told them they were
oh
that's weird
oh i can't jump on top of that huh
hmm okay let me go this way then
dude these [ __ ] amps
i hate
oh god
any imps in
here that just looked like a secret
passage oh god
yeah i ain't [ __ ] around
ain't no way bro ain't no wake huh
are you kidding
what
okay
worse than the game changed my mind imps
yes
i know these imps have like the same
moveset from those little wretches from
dark souls 3.
they have the exact same moveset
[Music]
what's going on over horror oh
that scared me
okay then
i get out of here thank you
dude this dungeon's hard
would you just spit on me
i
i bet i bet
did not come over here for a glove wart
nine i ain't gonna cap
i ain't gonna cap dog
i don't have anything that can help with
that
is this another weird dungeon oh i can
go up there
how do i
[Music]
usually i can just step on these things
and they're good
[Music]
there we go
aha
i'm very smart you could say
rick is a god
very smart indeed
yeah
i think revenants are the worst
in the game
definitely
all right who are you
cool
ow
that hurt
oh you heard a lot
especially when i have scarlet rot
does not help
it dodges good dodges let's go for this
my boy don't stag he a big boy
big boy
yeah he is really cool looking i like
his design
what is that
all right not bad he looks awesome
holy [ __ ]
rotten
grave keeper cloak
i just want to look at it
dude this is cool
but it is not rick
not for rick
it does look really cool though
favorite bloodborne weapon probably uh
just the cleaver i really like the
cleaver
yeah i gave you guys a little peep you
got a little peep ski doodle a little
peep
here i want to use my rooney voice
all right mark it off
good [ __ ] good [ __ ] guys i think we're
done with uh the snow field poggers
let's go
to
you guys want to go where do you guys
want to go next because we have a lot to
do in the lakes
mount glimer altus plateau
mountaintops we could go kill this
dragon king
let's go finish off the river i love how
i ask you guys and then decide for you
this is a democracy until i choose
that it is not okay
that was me
my adobe is acting up being a little poo
poo head
okay
how do i uh
i get to the sky again
facing cliffs ancestral woods
we got that mimic here we got no crown
the eternal city
cocoon of the imperium
basin
that's okay we like it when you take
charge are you guys into that you guys
like it
like being dominated
i don't think it means anything they
just look familiar
oh yeah yeah yeah
what up pale blood
yeah my vote matters more
uh there's another dungeon at the base
of the waterfall in the east part of the
snow field we got all the we got all of
them we already went there actually
makes the art in your stream thumbnail
it is in the description
no river map i guess not i'm not very
good at grabbing uh
things
like that i'm kind of
silly
if you haven't noticed i get very
distracted very
easily so you guys have to guide me
along
sometimes
because i'm a little bit uh yeah as i
said a little bit of goof
this is not where i want to be
it's here yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
what ending are you getting whatever you
guys choose when we get there
i believe we can beat ratagon and the
elden beast and still decide
it's not where i want to be either
it's mimics here let's see where's our
uh like this normal river
is it really here
whenever i finish that's when we'll end
daniel
whenever i finish
it's gonna go this way
oh
dude the underground makes no sense in
my brain
yeah that's knox stella
that's deep root
have i not been to the normal nocron
hold on a minute
i'm just gonna go here
it's gotta be that
it's right there
looking for the dragonkin
oh this isn't it either
this is too high
you go lower
or a well
i don't think i've gone to the normal
area yet
wow
interesting
you should be able to use torrent in the
elden bees fight absolutely agree
i think that would save that fight
because i don't know what you guys think
about the elden beast but i think it's
terrible
i love ratagon though ratagon is awesome
but eldon beast is
really bad
if we could use torrent though i think
it would save that fight
like then it would be good
it is really cool though but the fight's
not good
what it's
uh i see i see
open sesame
terrible's a strong word that's what i
think
all right let's dab all the way down as
rick would do
i mean this is does this not look like a
dab
i don't know how you can hate ratagon i
think ratagan's
one of the best final bosses ever
yeah i don't think i've ever well i had
to have gone down here i had to kill
the deer
oh we killed the other deer
oh [ __ ]
if we go up there and we've already been
here i'm going to be really confused
you know what i wish ratagan turned into
queen merica again
i wonder if she's really strong
nope never been here all right well
there we go
we gotta go kill the other deer then
well i know i can use torrent here there
we go
cringe
the deer looks really ugly close up i
mean it is like isn't it
dead
lore wise america wouldn't fight us
right i don't think she would i think
she would
talk to us about what her intentions
were but i don't think i think she would
be like ronnie i don't think queen
america would fight us
so i'm not sure
we don't know
america definitely did not like the way
things were that's why she did
everything in my opinion
yeah it's like a literal rotting corpse
all right well while we're here let's do
this
and then we'll kill the dragon
won't take too long
yeah i think radagon took over
the body to fight against us yes
dragon kin
soldier
yeah she wanted all of her demi-god kids
to become their own kind of lords
but she did want them to become a lord
that was the deal
you become a lord in your own way
or you'll become you'll amount to
nothing but sacrifices i think is what
the quote is
so there was a deal involved with that
yeah she'll kill you in an instant
ronnie can kill you
like pretty much instantaneously if she
wants to that's why i think she's the
most powerful one
just needs to kill you if she wants
it makes zero sense why dragonkin
soldier of knock stella is an
achievement
i mean he's a boss so
not an achievement but
oh i'm gonna need that
those things can kill you fast dog
why doesn't you kill radon or [ __ ]
i don't know that's a good question
i don't know
maybe she can't
not that she couldn't but maybe she
can't
i think we should have dlc dark souls 2
style yeah don't tell metal that metal
absolutely
despises dark souls 2.
despises it
which is why i think it would be funny
if that's the next game we play on
stream
would you guys want a dark souls 2
playthrough
i think that could be fun
because i don't think i ever finished it
we can just make fun of it if it's bad
maybe the rot erodes your body too
quickly maybe who knows
i all i know is radon couldn't instant
kill us insta-kill
what up md how you doing
all right i missed one somewhere
um
another completionist i don't know about
that i think we could play the game
kind of maybe review
it since i've never beaten it before we
could like
do a play through and then review it at
the end because i've seen people say
that they absolutely love dark souls 2
as well so
i just don't remember i played it so
long ago i have no like recollection of
like what i liked and disliked about the
game
and i've never played the dlc which i've
heard is the best part of the game
so i would like to do that too
there it is
i wonder how powerful ronnie would be if
she's still at her great room
i mean she wants nothing to do with her
great room she heated that [ __ ] up into
the [ __ ] moon
or she didn't do that
i think radon put it there
i got i got a video in the works for
that too guys i actually have two videos
uh that i'm working on right now that
should come out within the next week
wasn't that all of them
what up boys
dung eater lore video
not in the works right now
yes i have seen bomber's video on dark
souls 2.
i think we already marked off this deer
because i thought it was the other one
but here we are doing it so let's see
let's get it
so the other one's the regal ancestor
spirit this one's just ancestor spirit
uh there's another reason i'm waiting on
the rick video
besides 69 000.
it's actually really cool i'm excited
it'll be our first official sponsor
on the on the channel
you
one more
i'll take the hit
running away
there we go
first is official sponsor
so
i'm gonna wait until that gets all
worked out
so hopefully you guys will help me out
with that man
i'd appreciate it it's a big deal to me
to have a sponsor
like an actual one
that isn't uh me
you know like the last couple videos
i'll be like uh
this video is sponsored by you guys and
your amazing support here on youtube and
on patreon which is still a sponsor but
you know what i mean that's not like a
sponsor sponsor
so that's very exciting to be our first
one ever like a first real one
let's see if we mark that off
i'm not going to tell you what it is but
it's neither one of those
it's a good one i think you'll actually
really like it
okay so yeah we already marked it off so
where is um
dragonkin
how do i get there
[Music]
it's a real sponsor it's really cool i'm
actually super excited
let's see
it's real woods
you can't call our love sponsorship
yeah it's at the top of the rocks right
so
oh this this one takes you somewhere
else this one
oh
gotcha
i didn't know that i thought it took you
to
like just up the hill up here
yeah this is where i thought it took you
we've already been up here you can
literally run up here
he's near a cliff
do i have to go around up there like
that way kinda
wrong portal
oh
should i go back
i thought that was a little island
other one pass where blide was okay
thank you thank you
clyde was over here
on the hill right so a little bit
further this way
what's up new journeys how are you
favorite ship flavor
i love cheddar dog i love cheddar and i
love sour cream
sour cream and onion when you're feeling
it
absolutely slaps
collapse pillar
oh right got it thank you yep yep
thank you thank you
up here
i forgot about this
thank you thank you
scholar the first sin iron keep however
is the worst level from software has
ever made
i would i don't know i wouldn't know
get uh get rid of that since we don't
even have it in a moment
since we don't even have it no mo
it smells like feet
hey listen
that's fine
what's wrong with feet
you know
howie
i'm gonna kill you
right up that bunk hole baby bang
dead
mark it off
all right
river done
where do you guys want to go now we got
altus plateau we got mountaintops we got
mount glimer and we have the lake
and one dragon kin in the lake of rot
which man i'm gonna save that for later
we guys won't go
should we just go to laker rot and get
it over with bro
kill patches
all right where's patches tell me where
he is
you guys said he's in
like where
where'd you say he was
like hiding
it wasn't fair in missoula right
she's not
here jaded castle that's where he is
let's go find his bum ass and get rid of
him
let's go find his bum ass
here wait
there it is
we need to go do that one too silly
all right where is he
let me add him
murder
i'm out for blood he's near the boss
door
you little forehead
me like uh-huh
i don't think it's a shame uh i i had a
bit of a slip up that's all uh-huh
karma i should have stuck to what i know
best
no matter
i know i i can trust you uh gullible yes
but uh
a good soul
make certain that tanith gets this
dancers
castanets oh it's it's nothing it's just
makes me sick to see her all bent out of
shape
come on tennis back on your high horse
where you belong
hmm you're able then
then
i can rest easy
i'm not gonna kill him i'm not i'm not
so he's resting
all right let's go to tanith
he's eating right hard right now so
let's see how that goes
leave the kid alone
he does sim for tana
some [ __ ] reason
give dancers whatever that is
i have no need of that
i must continue devouring my beloved
lord
wow
oh you she did not
our lord's carcass is not easily
consumed
oh patches
oh
god
okay i'm not gonna kill her yet did you
guys say she went to uh
or patches went back to his cave
like for real for real
here
not killing her yet
not yet not yet
yeah that rejection was [ __ ] savage
dude
she ain't got no time for simps
i don't know if there are any girls in
the chat
because i can't remember who's a girl
and who's not sometimes
i just say guys all the time but uh
you know what never mind that's a stupid
question don't girls definitely simp for
guys right
i guess it depends on what age you're at
what's going on here
well well well
what thought you'd just help yourself to
a man's personal belongings
you scheming little faith patches we've
done this god's demand repentance
cough up your coin what
we've done this man what the heck
wait
don't tell me
is that you yes oh cripes
please wait what
i surrender i surrender i swear
dude
girl here i don't sip for guys though we
bat for the same team ah there you go
nice nice
glad to see we're on the same page
i'd never crush you
not even close thank you thank you
i mean did he just like forget who we
are ah
it's been ages since i've seen you
i didn't even realize it was you
took you for a demi-human or some such
you know how it is
just an innocent mistake
water under the bridge eh
back to business as usual
oh chat
hell spells i want to just eat him in
the air with my ash of war especially if
we keep running into the likes of you
hmm
maybe i set up another shop with the
lads
okay now where does he go
do i go uh
talk to him at the castle then you'll go
back to his cave okay so we did that
i'll set up another shop with the lads
i'm not going to kill him
you just stays here
reload
now you are to become a slave knight
that's it
rest and talk again
all right
okay
oh that was totally new to me
it's new to me too i haven't seen that
before
says you kill him
i want to
yeah i'll actually rest though
he sells stuff
can i kill him after
he's on our list chat we can't ignore
the list
the squad is the end of his quest
well
finally may today and just in time
for the grand reopening of patch's
emporium grand reopening won't need a
refund because everything is top-notch
all right what do you got
all right a little late on the shackle
business i might need that actually
um
i hear this parrying dagger's actually
really cool but rick has no use for any
of this [ __ ]
all right
cheers for that
i checked the cave after shaded castle
for me he wasn't there now here he is
the squat jester is a great crest
quest reward
i'm leaving it up to chat
all of you were saying no but there
might be people not talking in chat that
actually think you know what just kill
him bro
hill patches
yes or no
poll has started
i am going off of what this poll says
i don't care what it is
but i'm gonna do it
all right you better vote better vote
than people oh my god it's a 50 50 split
right up the middle
i don't think we can ignore the list
uh oh yes he's winning
he's on the list guys
he dies anyways i mean he's alive right
here
you've already sacrificed one on the
list who was that who did we
sacrifice i don't remember
kill that [ __ ] all right
you guys said yes
it's time
touch
[Music]
dab
on them haters
mark it off
mark it off boys
lim grave
boom
is done
done
you just called it a [ __ ] show i love it
dude
all right where do you guys want to go
now we got a lot to do in the lakes
mountain glimmier
um
mountaintops alta splateau
lakes because we've done we've done that
with lim grave caled leondell
dragonkin soldier of knox stella
oh let's go do that because i know how
to get there i'm gonna go do that
i just i just [ __ ]
hey guys where do you want to go next
okay we're gonna go here
you missed the boss in the snow fields
not according to my list
it may come up in a different spot
because i think some bosses aren't in
the right spot on the list
so we may have to come back to it
i use opera gx
really laggy over here
open sesame
you naruto fan i
i am i like naruto
it was the first anime i've ever seen
so it's probably why i like it so much
i've seen all of it
yes we killed astle in the snow field
shut up metal
you're a weeb too
are you ever gonna do a face reveal
probably not
all right million subs
i'll reveal my face
yeah i like one punch man i think i've
only seen the first season though
i
think
would you ever do a podcast
i don't know
i don't know
why i would do a podcast
or like how i would
like what would we talk about
gaming
because i would like to spread out
beyond elden ring with our content
howie that hurt
a lore podcast with vati
we talk about drugs we could
something completely unrelated to gaming
let's talk about
golf you guys like golf
i love golf
let's see
no other ants
talk about rocket league
how many of you guys in chat play rocket
league
still
you've probably all played it but do you
still play it
yes or no
also this area is really cool
nope
rocky league's lit
two years
it's boring now
couldn't agree more with that statement
talk about life
i could do that
never played
is that a nasa competition
no
okay metal
okay
you guys want to see what happened to
rocky league
let's do worldwide
interest over time in the last five
years
can you tell where the game went free to
play
right there
it was 20 bucks for four years
three four years
free to play
and then all of those new players
realized it was boring and it died
that's what happened to rocket league
can't take that serious it is still i
think rocket league is a great game
it's just so boring
good luck cj
i might be doing that myself soon
i think it was the most popular game
in uh during 2020 the beginning of 2021
i think rocket league was the most
popular game
i held tournaments
for thousands of dollars
on my twitch stream
they adding a racing element to it
i doubt it
how can a boring game be great because
the
the gameplay of it is great
now if you had to guess take one guess
why do you think the game died
because the game is boring
but take one guess
how long has it been
the the main reason i suppose
nothing i want
no i have not read or watched one piece
content drought
no i mean
that's a given there is a content
drought but what do you think was the
main reason
there is actually no hacking in rocky
league whatsoever there's you can't hack
in that game
no hacking
is there really nothing in there but him
kind of a wicked area just to have him
here
nope it's not because it's too sweaty
well i guess that's a part of it
it's not pay to play every car does the
exact same thing it goes the same speed
and it does the same everything except
for slight variations in the hitbox
everybody uses the free version anyway
the free car
and none of you guys have said it yet
it it being too sweaty goes along with
it but it's not the main reason
metal knows
the community is full of really young
kids
and what does that lead to
an insanely toxic community
i can't open my map because i got
enemies all around me
very toxic community
how do i get up there
little bubble blowing bubble buddies
i need to go around
hmm
is there like another door
i can't go to those broken pillars
and maybe i can
over here
the ree community is a great way to put
it
in there
owie
there's a continuation
northwest lavond is taking meteors to
the face
i mean is there nothing in here
oh
it can make bubbles
you can climb the rocks by the entrance
you're in
yeah i'm not seeing much any other way
head up to the main entrance
turn left and go down the cave that's
how you go up
not that but over here
you guys are telling me so different so
many different things
bruh
guys
guys
i'm leaving
it's not there there's no entrance in
there
i literally stood in there
looked around
am i blind or something
bro
okay
okay
got it
holy [ __ ] you guys are so awful
left turn around
go back
wrong way
right way
it's in the merchant's area
this is not anywhere remotely close to
the merchant by the way
this is way down
you all need to work on your directive
skills
not the best
not very good
is that what i think it is
[Music]
oh god
soup
that's the lake of rot
pretty cool though that we can see it
from up there
yeah remember when i said let's try and
do this through only chat
directions
are you guys understanding how hard that
is now
it's kind of funny
i don't really play nintendo games
yeah this is where the soldier is this
is probably one of the coolest like
aesthetic areas in the game like look at
this bro
this is so cool
he's sitting on a dragon skin this
dragon skin has cool
full lightning abilities
really
really
no see
and it can fly now
is that not really cool
now
i'm gonna die
holy [ __ ]
now it's dead
dead
yeah low level that guy would have
killed me 100
and see i i waited i waited to show you
guys the cool fight
god damn
no i haven't fought the one in the lake
of the rot should we just go do that
god that sounds horrible
might as well
all right let's mark it
off dragon or that's the one we just
need to fight we fought that one
now to the lake of the rocks
fight me jake no i'll fight your mom
i'm gonna fight your mama who is that
just walking around
what are you doing out there sir
all right where is it how do i get there
i don't have anything
i don't have any of the scarlet stuff
can i make it actually
consumables
oh you stay open when you hit them one
time
okay okay all right
oh damn this [ __ ] hits fast
uh i don't know if we can live through
this
i'm gonna go here actually and and go
another direction
is that that was eaten away at me wait
what
i went the wrong working way i'm so done
i want to do this
rick just doesn't care
[Music]
exactly
he's on the left oh my god i
so like over here
[Music]
that way
over there right
now
you said left side
this is left
in accordance to where we're facing
in the direction
[Music]
okay so over here then
all right i'm gonna go out here and go
to the right
your directions are so insanely hard
[Music]
[ __ ] it
stop
this is dangerous
oh there it is
this is mad chilling over here
nice
dad
why are you doing this like this dude
seemed to work
hey that worked
you can raise platforms around him
yeah
i bet you could
all right he's dead
done
perfect lake of rot done where do you
guys want to go now
i will actually let you choose this time
lakes
glamier
altus plateau
or mountain tops
soup
we already did everything in the
concentrated snow fields
done done done done
rick does not need platforms
lakes all you guys are all saying
different [ __ ]
i feel like we should do lakes because
we have a lot to do here
all right where's the albastar lord in
lorraine of the lakes
nope no vote you guys are all saying
different [ __ ]
oh right right below it neat
go right here
you miss the magma worm in the
concentrated snow fields it is just
listed wrong
great
it takes so long for you to get the
messages no it doesn't it takes like one
second after i ask a question
it's in an abergail
let's see
we can see evergills right
from the top
that right there
oh that's that little house
it's pronounced evergell
[Music]
shut up
thanks for pronounce like helping me
pronounce it better
by dancing sword woman
well who who the [ __ ] is melania's
teacher who the [ __ ] is melania
you can't see evergales until you've
been there it's not true you can see a
small little circle
what is that
it's jail
all right let's find this evergale
[Music]
it's just a rise
that right there
it's a puzzle tower
yeah we don't need to do that
[Music]
east of pope dog turtle
oh it's where we just were
should i just start looking up on the
wiki so we can actually get [ __ ] done
i guess it's like you guys giving
directions is just
awful
it's kind of fun until it's like holy
[ __ ] you guys are all telling me
different [ __ ]
different stuff
no
no
we will guide you
i don't know about that
it's over there
oh my game froze okay there we go
it's over there
oh my god it's in an evergale behind the
carrion manor
are you guys just saying [ __ ]
oh that looks like a circular pattern
right there
hmm
interesting can we go to the right over
here i don't think i've ever tried
i'm a woman and i'm horrible at giving
directions
listen
i'm not good with directions either i
don't think it's based on gender
oh look at that we can run right over
here
[Music]
doggies
random person
neat
i want 50 things on my screen telling me
where to go
no i just want chat to tell me hey look
at that it's never ever
ever gale
ever gale
ever gale
ever gale
look at that evergale
you know what i'm calling leonard
leonard still too i got so much [ __ ] in
my radon video because i called leonard
leonard and i'm just gonna keep calling
him that now
honestly
man he came out hot
laughs
got him
i call him that too dude so many people
were like
dude no one in the in
any part of existence has been called
leonard what are you even saying and i'm
like have you guys not heard of like
uh mid like medieval times like medieval
nights and [ __ ] like i swear people were
called leonard
and talking about a game that like has
that aesthetic and that vibe i'm like
leonard but no radon's horse is named
leonard
sure
sure it's leonard
i swear it's leonard but whatever
and then i i commented that one time
and then uh
and then vatividia made a video
where he said leonard and i'm like well
there it is that's what everyone thinks
now
all right all bastard lord dead electo
black knife ring leader
okay where's that where's electo
leonard sounds so much better
you are correct i was told by quite
literally thousands of people that i was
wrong so i i don't know
sounds way better than leonard
electo is in the ronnie quest end area
okay
so up here
oh we're wrecking bosses baby
it's however you take it uh not
according to some [ __ ] people dude
what's up jay
i don't know we're about to find alecto
whatever the hell that is
um
okay i don't want to ride around like an
idiot but you see just over here north
west corner
so the way i'm going yep
thousands of people like to put milk in
the bowl before cereal but that's just
objectively wrong i guess so
in here
moon folk
[Music]
eggles
oh there's an evergale over there
i'm just gonna call it that for the end
of time if they wanted it to be called
ever jail then they should have spelled
it with a j
that's my ignorant opinion
what's up javier how are you man
hope you're having a good day
yo what up
so it's a black it's a named black knife
assassin
holy [ __ ] he's really strong oh my god
like really strong
hanky boy
[Music]
[Music]
luck there's definitely no joke
[Music]
or electo is a girl right it has to be
it's
they're newman's
[Music]
[Music]
i think all black knife assassins are
women
whoa that's what malakath does
[Music]
dude this is nuts
y'all have to read if i get an item
description here on something
um oh
wow okey-dokey then
that killed me so fast
it's kind of a male name do we really
know i don't think gender matters
whatsoever in the lands between
not even a little bit
when it comes to names and [ __ ]
on
[Music]
female in greek myths there you go
[Music]
i just stop doing that
[Music]
move set
[Music]
oh that
[Music]
no please
don't kill me
thanks
that hurts
rick isn't scared of you
he is however scared of that attack in
particular though
black knight
yeah that's not who we fought though
hmm okay
isn't that something extremely strong
too
now all the roly-polies
no match for rick
yeah wipes mimic
he's just her daughter it's one of the
best in the game well let's read it
anyway
peach is one of the assassins who on the
night of the plot imbued her black knife
with the ruin of death in slough godwin
the golden
he was the daughter of black knight of
the black knight ring leader electo and
was killed protecting her mother during
their fight from the royal capital okay
of their flight from the royal capital
so probably after they killed godwin
they tried to escape
and then didn't go well got it okay cool
that's lit
remember like if you read like a newman
rune
all of those assassins are newman and
queen america's newman as well
okay let's let's mark it off mark it off
bell-bearing hunter so i'm assuming
you're a merchant at night
i know of this merchant is it this one
at night
or
is there one here no
it's the only merchant i know of in
lurinia i think
by the turtle priest at night
somebody explain what a newman is it's a
different race
outside of the lands so like they came
from outside the lands between
so
do i have a newman rune
i have a hero's rune
oh let's do this
don't crash game
we're a lore guy newman
newman's rune
uh the new men are said to come from
outside the lands between and are in
fact the same stock as queen america
herself so there's that
newman again
black knife armor set
um the assassins that carried out the
diesel night
that carried out the deeds of the knight
of black knives were all women and
rumored to be newman is close ties with
queen america herself so
there you go
it's pretty cool
america is gary newman
yes
there you go that's the answer
there is war master shack and the pope
yeah that's in limb grave though not
here
uh do i have to go in here
would turtle pope not be here
turtle pope
dog pope
i think i need to rest one more time
thanks bester appreciate it man glad you
like him
he has to despawn okay i got it so the
turtle pope won't be there
and he gone
hey yo what up
hey yo what up cud
you did
mark it off boys
on to the next one
boom
black knife assassin just a normal one
i'm assuming that's in a catacomb of
some kind
also keep in mind that we may have
already done these at certain points uh
and just not marked them off correctly
the river well
okay by the way that bell bearing hunter
in caled is broken it is way too strong
anyway
yeah we chat we absolutely slap them
cheeks right there hey where's that a
normal so high road catacombs
where's that
i can always do this if i if i have seen
it so high road
catacombs
there's so many places in the lake bro
i have not discovered it yet in a hole
to the east of the earth tree
of the mid like the smaller tree
probably
archery
and you said to the east of it
so up here somewhere
okay
you go back up here
okay
so based on where i am now where is it
do i need to go like down here
at the tip of the pp it's crazy how i
know what you're saying okay
got it
the tip of the peepee
what's up sir killington
great directions guys good job
good job great directions at the tip of
the peepee
oh i'm out of here [ __ ] all that nope
nope
at the tip of the peepee
yeah i gotta go lower
you be eachine congratulations sir
you have beaten sakiro then
in one way or another
bro how do i get down here
this might have been sketch and go this
way
yeah those are the directions we need
guys you have to put it in a very simple
terms for me to understand
exactly
you can't say left or right you have to
say
at the tip of the pp for example
yo whatever
yo what up
i feel like melania's overrated very
easy boss you can shove that opinion
right into
whatever you want because that's fine
i really am fizzy
i am it's it's just true
there are two bosses in here all right
we gonna find out
black knife catacomb
oh the beast eye quivers
iii multiplayer is still offline
they said they were addressing it though
like they're gonna try and fix it soon
i think you got elden ring right guys
i would imagine they're not really
focused
on ds3
but they're gonna try
oh
i know this one
look how smart i am
[Music]
see how smart that was
i'm a very smart man
but a very simple mind
that's a hole
on a scowy
going down the hole
[Music]
hey yo
hey yo what up
hidden wall hidden boss i i will go back
we'll go back
you know how it would be
you know how this stuff works one little
step at a time you know what i'm saying
one day i'll be playing this game and
experience the lore of the game and
struggle with melania onto eternity
i don't think you're alone my friend
yeah you missed the hidden wall ball you
missed the hidden boss round okay we'll
go back no it's okay
it's okay
boys do be what it be doing
everyone calm down
you have a little crush on melania
all right cemetery shade it looks like
these things are actually low-key
i was gonna say hard to fight but
considering i hit it one time and it
almost died
there we go
all right let's go to the other one
i hit it one time
it was done
what the dog doing
what the dog doing bro
we want that for [ __ ]
melania is bae you don't have to hide it
i hate her guts
i think she's a big stupid
doodoo head
that's my answer
[Music]
black knife assassin this is what we
wanted
man
get absolutely
poo-pooed on dude
black knife print
kind of item was that
on the night of black knight someone
stole a fragment of
death
a fragment of death from malacath the
black blade and imbued its power into
the assassins daggers this mark is
evidence of the ritual and hides the
truth of the conspiracy
give it to roger dude roger is long gone
dead guys
so that's a little late for that
unfortunately
but that's what you give to him for him
to be like yeah it was ronnie right
pretty sure
okay we got two of them in there
yeah he dead as hell he died a while ago
but that you gave it to him and he's
like yeah it was ronnie who did the
whole thing
okay boom cemetery shade is also dead
bulls the carrion knight
where is that
can get a black knife
i think we got one let me look at it
it's a blade of calling
a ship shar
um
never mind i don't see it
that's a gale
all right we're at though
to the west of leonia southwest of the
lakes
south west so did we already do it no
that's ring leader
that's the kaku
ooh is it over here
mind the right area
that's the rise let me go here real
quick
it's possible i've already done it
i mean it looks like i've already done
the kaku
[Music]
ah stars there are so many stars
in the sky in this game
yep we already did this one
uh
what boss was in here
was that bulls i remember us fighting
bulls actually i remember going huh his
name is balls
i'm gonna mark it because we definitely
fought someone named bulls thousand
percent
haha his name is bulls
okay
so we did that one uh clean rot knight
clean rot
night
yeah you guys remember that i made that
stupid joke
exactly
poor guy
okay clean rot knight
didn't we fight a spear and staff as
well
let's focus on this one clean rot knight
i'm such a weirdo stupid poopoo head
sometimes
you fought a sword in a mace
uh
inverted pp in front of stormville
so down here
we'll have to go there then
caleb
inverted pp
what do you project what are you
protecting
nope
inverted does not mean
that
thank you
okay
okay
[Music]
that's pretty
why does this look fake
it's not
it's not fake
not stupid bat
owned
i'm faster than you
get on
you big
[Music]
damn
this guy got freaking owned huh what do
you got oh a sage's robe
that's gallery's thing right
two for one
oh god
okay this is not what i wanted
i love fighting flying enemies
it's so much fun
there we go
is that all that's over here any secret
passage
you undressed him
maybe cool i don't know yet i'm just
gonna i'm focusing on one thing at a
time and right now i just want to beat
our completionist thing
i also have two videos that i want to
get done and get out within
uh
the next week
but i've been
very into this completionist run
wow this isn't really annoying
okay
i love flying enemies in this game
there's so much fun to fight
it's so much fun to fight against
that entire situation just gave me
anxiety like i have anxiety now
all right sick
like i now just have that
yes i'm on pc
up statue of america what does that mean
probably a big stupid doodoo head up
here
let all these guys chill
that rip is a blood spammer i cannot
relate
he had a limp
you see that
three hits dead
you know that was probably like a really
cool boss because it's in like a really
cool area like this looks sick and then
i just three tap it
all right
on to the next one
clean right night dead crystalline spear
and staff where's that
what's your build
this is the god build
yes we went to radon's
in the radon fight area we did um do the
catacomb over there
lucaria tunnel ah that's right
i didn't have the uh the runes for it
it's over here yep i know where that is
not the runes the
stones
stone sword keys
we just witnessed a murder
yeah if that was supposed to be a fight
yep i know where this one is
which leads to such a weird area of the
game
like that takes you up a giant elevator
and up some stairs to give you one item
kind of weird
we're making a lot of progress today
guys we are getting it done
we won't need any progress after this
because we're gonna be done
press one in chat that you're you're
gonna be sad
that the series is gonna be over
gonna be sad
this cave is actually really scary
yep a lot of ones a lot of ones
but i'll keep streaming i might take a
little break from streaming like a week
or something and then we'll figure out
something else to do look how creepy
this looks
like that's cool dude
do you think there'll be dlc for eleanor
this year yes
i do
knee heel
can't open that
but yes i can it's the only thing i can
open your stupid forehead
i'm going to destroy you
this is work
rick wishes
oh yeah i forgot there's some stupid
head
i just refer to all enemies attack me in
this game as stupid poo-poo heads
yep i would say september or december
for
dlc
and stagger you
there we go that's what we want baby
this is radon's great room
rick does not care
i will take all of the hits
and show you my full power
rick doesn't even need to dodge
okay
get ricked
okay
boom
oh no okay i know where the death bird
is i do
it's more than time
my game crashed okay we're good
are you going to buy the official
strategy guide put lol
maybe probably i'm going to need it even
though i'm beating the entire game and
everything in it but
uh i'll take it for more
information imagine they make a lore
book i'm pretty sure i would
i would be so happy if they made a lower
book
okay terra magica isn't this so
pointless up here though like you can't
go anywhere up here it's kind of weird
anyway
okay death right bird
is where we met raya
um
let's buy some stupid rock over here at
night
if they made this game into a movie how
long do you think that movie would be i
don't think this game could be a movie i
truly don't
there'll be lore in those guides
nice
it's back over here right
let's buy some big uh fallen ruin
yeah this right here
yeah we're fighting a death bird
there we go
not a death rate
this game's predictable
i think that's the second stupid thing
you said
i think you're just saying really offset
like uh
opinions
do you think bloodshot
bloodborne should get a sequel i would
love for there to be a sequel but i
don't think they need one
they really don't
um also miyazaki doesn't really like
sequels he only did
he miyazaki only made dark souls 3
because they [ __ ] up dark souls 2 so
bad
didn't i already beat these urgery
avatars
we're gonna have to go check north east
and south west
yeah i feel like he's trolling okay
bait
it's bait
miner avatar
minor archery let's go there let's give
it a shot
yep
bait
welcome lance
the base of the peepees
i would like to see bloodborne be
remastered for the ps5 and put on pc
even though i don't think it needs to be
remastered per se
oh i haven't okay lit oh i would have
died little w okay now we won't
yeah a lot of people like dark souls 2
but miyazaki wasn't involved in the
making of dark souls 2.
so then he made dark souls 3
really
[Music]
run
thanks for killing your helpers for me i
appreciate it
yeah bloodborne and 60 60 fps or more
would be amazing
i think that's their next step with
bloodborne
and i'm not kidding you guys i am
straight up not kidding if bloodborne
were to get a pc port or like let's say
it gets remastered and put on all
platforms like xbox ps5
pc
i think it would sell
just as good if not better than eldon
ring
make it make it 20 bucks
i think it i think it would sell just as
many copies
for real for real
okay this was north east
one right oops
yep now let's go check southwest
waste
i thought you said
east
yeah it would be a genius business
decision but we all know that from
software like i feel doesn't really care
about that like they just like making
good games and making new stuff
that's why they made sakiro it's why
they made elden ring dark souls
bloodborne all kinds of different stuff
whis
thought you said
or east thought you said waste
ah balls
balls
it is sony's decision that's true i
don't know how long their contract was
with bloodborne though
i have no idea you know sony is like can
you can we get
a remastered version of bloodborne to
put on ps5 i think that would sell
really well
two
okay it looks like we already beat this
one
what's up achilles how are you
okay
so we did
we are you're killing it right now we're
actually almost done with the lakes
glintstone dragon sermog
and a doula
we've definitely killed both because we
did ronnie's questline so yes
is there a godskin noble fight in lorena
the lakes
yeah we did a doula we we definitely did
both dragons because we got the key and
we finished ronnie's quest
divine tower
oh then we did that right right right we
did that that's not even a boss okay
uh knights cavalry
i don't know where one is here
uh is it this bridge
yes
that's not a ba it would be a boss okay
i think i know what to do
so it's night time and then this should
be
a knight's cavalry
yep
rumors are bloodborne was originally
supposed to be demon souls 2 kind of
game but then they changed it during
development
well i bet they're happy about that
bloodborne sold amazingly didn't it
what what are what are bloodborne sales
like to this day
it has to be really good right
maybe i only know about like the
community loving it
oh you're not dead huh
here we go
bloodborne's my least favorite
that's crazy bro
okay royal revenant
2 million
oh [ __ ]
that's not that's
what 10 million copies less than eldon
ring
i mean alden ring was marketed so much
better
maybe that's why
yeah not even close to elden ring ruins
next to
eg oh i know where that is okay got it
yeah is it just a cult following
oh it is only ps4 so it sold two million
copies just on
ps4
that that's really good
that's really good
actually now when you think about that
one console
outdated console
yeah that's really good i didn't think
about it like that good point
good point
imagine if they had it on all of them
how well it would sell oh god no
[Music]
anything other than a revenant
jesus
thank god i killed that fast oh my god
those are awful
they weren't as big as they are now i
will say that from software did
way more marketing
for elden ring than i've ever seen them
do like way more than sakiro bloodborne
dark souls 3 all of them they did so
much more
really good marketing as well
okay
spirit collar snail where is that
where the heck is that
spirit collar snail that thumbnail is
straight heat yo right
dude check out the uh the artist's name
is in the description if you guys are
curious and thank you for the ten
dollars
i really appreciate that thank
you think you already did spirit collar
snail
did i
i want to check i want to check
it's growing rapidly yeah
but thank you again for the 10
eli's dragon ball content
thank you man i really do appreciate
that
you killed him already near the minor
archery
i did
was it a boss
well you get big enough blizzard's
disease sets in and rots your brain i
don't think from software is ever going
to do that i i believe in from software
although i thought the same of cd
projekt red when they made witcher 3 and
then they made cyberpunk and that
completely [ __ ] flopped
i mean for what cyberpunk was it was a
glitchy [ __ ] mess but i thought it
was a good game
you did yes it was a boss
oh okay yeah we did do that okay i'll
mark it off
um and then last thing in the lakes is
the uh tibia mariner
is that um
where is that
here
maybe
no
by the tower
the divine tower
divine tower cemetery
cemetery
is jar barn still just mad chilling over
there i'm just going to go here and
we'll look around
near the artist shack okay
thank you thank you
[Music]
south of artist
going
heading south
let me give that guy a little little
smack
that's all
not [ __ ] with the wolves because
they're just playing being cutie
patooties
yeah i really like
skyrim
skyrim was my favorite game for a very
very long time
i wish you could pause you really are
saying only bad takes right like you're
purposely only saying bad takes doom
slayer
i'm pretty sure you are
but
hey
you know
what level are we
143.
i've never played oblivion
[Music]
guys am i missing something here i
missed it
i just went right past it
also i could i could have yeah i could
already done it as well
you are okay i was like man bro
go back to the tower there's a cemetery
oh i see yeah we've done this it's in
the water right over here yep yep yep
or we may have not done it let's see
it would just be in the water right here
okay yep
we did it
already did it before
all right the lake's done
i say we go to mount glamiere
say we do
where's demi human queen mortgage
who's
heiress permabans 50 people per stream
we don't ban a lot of people
unless you're being really bad
what up johnny thanks man
i played subnautica below zero and hated
it
i really like subnautica though
subnautica is one of my favorite games
of all time but subnautica below zero is
poop
you just said you were doomed shut up
all right where's
margaret mark margaret whatever however
you say it
and we don't even i just yell at people
for backseat gaming i don't ban them
demi-human queen margaret can be found
by heading down to the lowest floor of
the volcano cave
a player can jump down from any of the
ledges in the cave or walk down the
southern path
okay that doesn't help that's very
descriptive but still doesn't help me i
need like pp
i'm just going to go here i need like pp
directions
hey i'm glad i can help
tenno
glad i can help man
so you know more descriptive pps
that's what the wiki says okay okay well
they need more pp descriptions uh okay
so you said
lowest floor of the volcano cave
huh
there's a cave
what
not in the manor there's a bunch of
ladders you have to climb over the
entrance to volcano manor
to mount glimmer
it's like over here
if you really think about it atomically
everything is a pp
i don't know about that
but you go ahead
and uh yeah
oh azure is gone
i got his armor though it's kind of sick
it looks like the tip top portion of
mount glimmer
like up here
you're way the [ __ ]
the planet's a ball the universe is
filled with balls
man speaking of balls you guys are
really gonna like the new uh
sponsor i'm sure you can make your own
assumptions by that
wouldn't let me use torrent on the
bridge
hello
there we go
all right i'm going over here going over
here
i'm not saying anything yet
i gave you a tip
nice
volcano cave
whoop
hey i'm just excited we got a sponsor
you guys gonna help me out with that
when i unveil it
sometime this week
i'd really appreciate it does it help me
out a ton
ew
yeah it's a big deal to me that is the
first sponsor i've ever gotten i'm not
gonna tell you exactly what it is yet
but
i don't use tinder i don't use any
dating website at all
okay
let's go
whoa
purple eyes
dude this is such a bloodborne boss
just gets rid of her
thing
her staff
dead
oh this is where you get the cannon huh
okay cool
nice
dead right good [ __ ] good [ __ ]
margaret dead
archery burial watchdog windham where is
that
windham
ancient dragon lassonix we actually
fight him here
yeah she just she eats that staff bro
it's cool
sure hope you make more lore videos oh
yeah i got two in the works man
um i use one fp flask just in case i
need it
wyndham
catacombs makes sense where's that
there more catacombs in this area
wyndham ruins
[Music]
it's got to be close to over here yeah
the ancient dragon will fly away if you
don't kill it so fast so it won't count
so that'll still count okay
um
it's the three banger okay this way
is that
got it i need to go up i think there's a
ladder over here
yes please remind me to do that
please remind me to record the ending
for rick
we need elden ring too the game just
came out man
we need more
more
if that's the ending you guys choose
i think any ending with rick in it will
work
for the video
three months after eldon ring's release
we need eldon ring too right now
big dog the game just came out bro
oh i could have just done that
fringe
i can't go this way either
we need it at least eldon ring five
oh
is this dog just laying next to his
owner
oh
[Music]
i'mma leave him be we need to go around
i already gotten this
yeah i could probably go up here is
great i'm gonna just keep going
we need ronnie's feet dlc
yep
yep
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm not going in there yet
i think i have to
let's go in here and see what's at the
bottom
oh
the eldest ring
we need elden ring battle royale do you
guys like battle royales
because i don't
i think battle royales are looting
simulators
with random bursts of fun
and they're boring
it's pretty much just running around
until you find stuff
found
yeah everything's better with friends
though oh [ __ ]
i play apex occasionally too but i'm
falling out of it
just because battle royale
boring
what was that skeleton doing
yeah i'm really good at apex when i'm uh
when i take sleeping pills
[Music]
not where you wanted to go oh good dodge
mr skellington
yep i'm a drug addict
what's funny is that's exactly what i
took was melatonin and i decided to play
apex until i fell asleep and i literally
got
like the best
kill of my life
in apex
going for boys
that was stupid
i shouldn't have done that
ow that hurt
stop it
get some help
hey
nope you go in there you just die no fun
that's so dumb my god
i can make it
scared yeah
no
[Music]
god dang it now i have to do that all
again
free
man my voice can go really high huh
i could have gone
look
dark souls 2 moment really god damn it
oh yeah there's chariots in dark souls 2
run
do i just take the hit here
oh boy okay i can go right here
i think we're fine
can i just go down here what's down
like anything
please don't come all the way down here
thank you
nothing
that's one way to do that
right
that was so [ __ ] pointless i wish i
didn't [ __ ] do that now i'm mad
god damn it
hey now we know right
now we know
positive mindset
god damn it bobby
we sell propane and propane accessories
oh
god damn it bobby
i'm stupid [ __ ] idiot
okay
why i pick that up i'll never know
die
oh
oh you
mother fricker dude
my name is tank hill
and i sell propane and propane
accessories
and if you don't
you're cringe
and imagine being french in 2022
lol double you
here we go
you buy the sword off a merchant
oh hello
got a bloodhound night
not anymore it's dead
neat neat oh oh oh oh [ __ ] that's a lot
of armor
god damn
tank hill is the lord the elden needs
that bro frank
thy propane befits a crown bobby
the propane
fits
a crown
i'll be
nice
nice
do i kill this thing can i kill the
knight or the chariot or whatever
i can't i drop on its head
do i even want to do that
do i have to i need to go that way right
yeah the artwork for the thumbnail is in
the description by the way
[ __ ] god damn it bobby
this is so cringe
ah
what in tarnation is happening here
well what the [ __ ] do i do now
god damn it bobby
now i'm in like hank hill mode
well [ __ ] chat we didn't open the door
oh we just open it
okay every other
every other thing you gotta do a thing
you gotta you gotta pull a lever but
this one you don't
god damn it bobby
all right fair enough
all right what's down here
it's a doggy
now it's a dead dog
good job guys
good job
death root let's go
we need that we need death root okay so
we killed we did not kill wyndham yet
we just killed the red wolf champion
that's great this one doesn't count so
we're just gonna check it because he
just flies away and we killed him later
on
uh
okay
let's continue on to wyndham
how do i get over here
maybe i have to just go right here
check it off
check it out boys
oh my god what's the voice you did when
you were playing red dead oh you mean
you mean arthur morgan
yeah
well
another day
lands between
it's right
yeah
that tree
make it makes a good fire
really do
well
we're here in windham
wyndham rune
yeah
well
[ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] lost god damn it
what's [ __ ] new
rick's lost
i'll just trot around till i find the
boss
i'm not getting notified when i stream
well that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
you should turn on notifications then
you [ __ ] forehead
sorry
hey looks like we've already been here
is this where wyndham would be down her
oh this looks
here we
wait we were here earlier
no this is not where
i've got a plan arthur
you always have a plan dutch
and your plans are always sussy
baca as the kids say
dusty baca
hank day out of this
i just want to know what the hell is
sushi [ __ ]
it doesn't matter hank
shut up
god damn it arthur
it's just what the kids say that's it
well they sound [ __ ] stupid
yeah i know
that's true
god
okay now i'm getting hyper i'm at the
part of the stream where i'm hyper now
okay
oh is it that
we lost
yep i'm two people now
guide me mommy no i already went to that
one
cat what am i missing where's wyndham
where's wyndham
is her cave back here
i closed my eyes for a moment thought i
was listening to two different people
well maybe you were
i don't know
could be the same person
that's where the statue was pointed i
just went down there
i just went down there
right here
maybe there's another one
yeah but there's no boss down there
there's no bossy baca
north
all right hey
[Applause]
look at that right there yeah that's
what we need right there baby
that's what we need right there
when
i don't even know what that means
god damn it sub-zero
ow ow ow son of a [ __ ]
that hurt
that hurt my balls
yeah that's death
okay okay nothing to ride that thing up
on lit
i'm over this
amongst us
we did the same attack
just keep swimming oh my
poop
it's volley from the sky
what are you doing here
you're cringe
i am melania blade of mikala
and i sell propane and propane
accessories [ __ ]
get out of here
we need a combo between america and
ratagon
well
nobody knows what the [ __ ] they sound
like
here here's how i imagine it going
no it's my turn to use the body
no it's not you had it yesterday
no i didn't you're misremembering
you used the body yesterday
i need to use it today we talked about
this
i don't what x oh
you used thou body yesterday
thy can't have body to thy days in dairo
thou art cringe
is that good
thou art a cringe lord
i think that's pretty good
good enough
hopefully the door is all the way back
at the beginning i don't remember seeing
it
i'm not grabbing the flowers because we
already got all of them
[Music]
no that's a death
there it is
oh god
[Music]
damn
[Music]
there's a [ __ ] laser beam
well
he's dead
the hell was that one called
uh windham got it okay kindred of rot
didn't we kill this is a flower right we
definitely killed this flower
perfumer trichia is that if that's a
flower
then we killed it
perfumer is a person
okay then it's not
chris please stop begging people to play
elden ring with you thank you
here uh
i need to go poop chat like i ain't
gonna cap i gotta poop right now um i
will be back in five minutes we're gonna
take a five minute short break everyone
go get your snackies
go get your snacks take your bathroom
breaks i'm gonna do the same i will be
right back
oh okay that was my controller
everyone go take a small break very
short break brb
i have returned
i am back
chat said to pinch it off and get back
here
chat wants to know where you keep your
poop knife
what the hell is a poop knife poop knife
poop knife
were you giving birth in there guys i
have to walk across the house up the
stairs and across the house to the
bathroom okay and then to come and then
i pooped and had to walk across the
house down the stairs and across the
house again shut up
all right
i think that's a fast poop my dad poops
he takes an hour to poop
every day
honestly because he's sitting there on
his toilet or like on his phone
do people use a knife to cut their poop
that's so gross
anyway what are we on okay let's
continue let's continue on continue
forth
we need to keep it going we still have a
lot to do man so a lot to do bro
actually not really we're almost done uh
kindred abroad no what did i do to the
list
i fixed it
where's the kindred rot
kendra rat
yes i wiped
that goes without saying
what do you think i got a poopy butthole
that's gross
that wasn't even that long you guys
seat water cave
okay where's that
oh this is mount glimmer beef water
river
i'm assuming there's a cave up in that
[ __ ]
i'm just gonna go here and go through
there
yes i wash my hands all of this goes
without saying bro
yeah what are y'all my mom
when are you releasing your next soldier
of godric video
um
there's probably gonna be one video in
between that one
actually there will be
yes i flushed
the toilet
up i see
i see
it yup
got it
oh i couldn't swing
there's a merchant
or actually
did you say your prayer
when you cast the swole stop
stop it
uh we bought all these already didn't we
where can i get more
where can i get more
more power
oh my god
oh we're doing every boss until the
final boss
where can i buy more of these
um merchant in mogwin's palace
yo straight up dog
are you being dead deadass
you being deadass for real with me right
now bro
all right
bet
see if this boy right
uh we have a checklist in the
description if you want to see it's
we're almost done we're actually getting
pretty close
i don't know how long it's going to take
me to be ratagon and the elden beast
though that might be really tough with
this build actually
uh however i am a god gamer so it might
be easier than we think as well
we'll just have to have to wait and see
you know
i'm dead
i ran right past it
oh i didn't turn in patch's bell
god damn it
i'm going back up here i'm gonna go turn
that in
ow
my back
yep should have done that
rataga i'm gonna punish you i heard i've
hurt two of his puppies
yeah if we can beat melania then we're
good
that's true
and i did it with this build
people telling me i couldn't [ __ ] do
it look how many of these we have to
turn in god
dang it
all right
look out for stone sword
zero
bro that didn't even make a difference
dog like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] bro
i don't got a farm i need stone sword
keys [ __ ]
okay
god dang it
bobby
okay i'm not doing that again
i'm gonna see if this one has some too
we're gonna buy all of them
go to the bell bearing shop you mean the
one i was just at
you forehead
they well if i go to the main shop
then it should sell me everything right
or is that not how that works
i need a stone sword he's [ __ ]
a different menu item are you serious
what
are you being dead ass
you guys are [ __ ] with me
[Music]
yeah i bet i scared you
i'm afraid you don't need to apologize
okay bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye where was i i i
i i man i'm getting hyper holy [ __ ]
mount glimmer
you
oh that's crazy yeah well that sucks
well we've we found five we're fine but
that is good to know thank you
wait you guys are morbid with me
that was a quick poop i'm just starting
cat gave me [ __ ] that i was too slow
i mean what do you guys poop in like 30
seconds you don't scroll through a
couple tick tocks while you poop
oh that's two
oh god
hey y'all poop shame me you did
you did
you
did that
wannabe soldiers
i am the soldier of god himself
and i am known
as rick
the all-powerful
soldier of god
yeah give it at least 10 minutes with a
dozen tick tocks
ao facts bro facts
nah i bet you're still in the bathroom
crashy i bet you are
that's where that flower is
a big ass cave this reminds me of
subnautica going down like this
dude i would love to play subnautica
again that that would be really fun
okay we're fine
the screaming was
not me
it wasn't me
it was you
my friend just told me your build is
stupid well your friend's a stupid big
fat poo poo head how about that
yeah my build's really stupid
as i tank all those hits and three shot
these [ __ ]
boom
we're dead as hell
they dead as hell
okay is the perfumer in here as well
like in this area
[Music]
you call that a scream pathetic
there you go
my vocal range is insane
i like the lighting in here
perfumer is in the unsightly catacombs
okay where's that
unsightly catacombs
there is no stronger
than
rick
the almighty
the all-powerful the mic didn't pick it
up good it's a good mic then
good
good
good
to the left
of the perfumer ruins
i don't know where
that is
going to go over here
[Music]
okay
so
yep don't have that down more on the map
like down down hither
or down hither
by the craftsman shack
i'm gonna go down here
because i think that's what you guys are
talking about but i could be totally
wrong
because i'm a stupid
that's the answer nope they're saying no
now after saying yes right there
it's across the giant gap
okay
let me get into a spot that i can rest
and then i can trap the spot you want
i'm really [ __ ] hyper
and it's kind of cringe across this
giant ass [ __ ] gap are you kidding me
how the [ __ ] do i get over there
[Music]
how the [ __ ] do i get over
[Music]
hmm
okay how do i get over there
oh down even more this way
okay
like this
i'm gonna go here
then we gonna go up
so you guys aren't giving me proper
directions
you're not
you're not saying pp directions
you're saying down
oh man am i annoying
probably
you said it's in a catacomb though
ah
here we are
oh
oh
a perfume bottle how
i got four-headed
by a
flower i don't know i got you on moot
bro then how did you hear me you're
impressive
down here
only one not two [ __ ] you
we only have one left
we can buy more
bingo bingo bongo on my balls what okay
[Music]
what though
got some misbegotten down here huh
nope we're doing all bosses and quest
lines that's it
rick does not cook
cooking
hooks for rick
right now i have 50 stone sword keys and
you only have one
me
i have lots of stone sword keys
is it a double boss fight is this one
that i can just open nope i need to hit
a contraption
okay then
[Music]
it's a two boss fighter huh
oh my god
they all asleep
no they're all dead
winged misbegotten
ashes first big chungus
[Music]
hey yo yo mama big chungus
and that's what i love about her bro
i'm in a weird mood and i like it
oh she has a shield
and a shield for him
no she blocked it
nevermind
she's running away
yeah that's why
let's go
mount glimmier
complete
boom baby
what do we got left
mountaintops of the giants and altus
plateau we have a lot more to do in
altis plateau let's see if we did the er
tree avatar there
open them up in them alt
probably right there let's go
find out
[Music]
[Music]
uh terribly sorry do you guys purposely
like scare the [ __ ] out of them
okay
um
she's dancing like a stripper hey
somebody go get her she dancing like a
stripper
i'll stop now sorry
can we have worm face in here as well
whoa
is this worm face
yeah it is
ew
it's spreading covet everywhere
oh god
that's not the head i wanted
there we go
why didn't he eat me
i feel like he could have eaten me
anyway warm face
jack
um i mean is there an avatar around here
as well
maybe on the other side
some more
wormy boys
hmm
there's no avatar here
is there another tree
in the plateau
this count is altus pluto probably
i don't think there's a
one here either is there
let's go check
yeah we already killed one we just
killed worm face
[Music]
oh that's a dead tree
this one also doesn't have one then
where is it
oh that doesn't even count as a boss
does it
death bird good good we need this
death snails
not the death snails
i hate fighting you
you guys think they kind of look like
babies
like their head looks like a doll of a
baby kinda
that's what i see
[Music]
this thing's owning me right now
[ __ ] snail
i can't hit its head
there we go
death bird eliminated
[ __ ] boys good [ __ ]
uh
sick not even on the list
excellent
excellent
we needed to do it anyway oh god tree
sentinel duo
oh
needs to be done
it uh
needs needs to be done
wait that i went to the wrong one
warping behind them
yeah doesn't that not work
anymore
rick can beat them
one on two same time this is gonna be
easy
right guys
yup
[Music]
that one's dead
this one didn't even notice
[Music]
what
tanked
boom baby
easy
okay
where's an ancient hero of zamor here is
that like a
an ebergale
an ebergeel
there's a falling star beast over here
as well
bro so easy bro that was so easy bro i
don't even think this is a boss though
is it
is it just a normal enemy
uh
yeah never mind it's not even a boss
spear and ring blade i swear i i did
that i swear i did that
okay
we're gonna ever get that looks like a
cave right there
that we haven't gone in
tomb guarded by a black knife i i i bet
i'm gonna go in that
cave um man we still need to get all the
stuff for
dung eater as well
we'll do that when we finish all the
bosses we'll go get all the death root i
mean if we beat all the bosses we should
have all the death route but maybe
there's certain enemies we have to beat
i don't remember
whoa
i find this area really creepy
yeah the eater's still down under
hey
very nice very nice
rick does not use elevators
rick has no need for them
and leave everybody alone we're here for
the boss and only the boss
spaghetti on toast
that's some [ __ ] i've never heard of
would i be willing to try it
abso [ __ ] lutely i would
wow we got the spear boys down here
are they glitched
mark it off
easy
dead okay sainted hero's grave and
sage's cave
sainted hero's grave huh
looks like i don't know where those are
i haven't found them yet
so
that looks like something huh
oh that's a windmill never mind scratch
that
that looks like something
that's what we want right there right
there friends
where am i right now
i see
okay
it's just a windmill
somebody come get her she dancing like a
stripper hey
wait what am i doing
go back up
dumbass
i was taking a drink
okay
wait no
oh is there something else down here
i'm just confused now and i'm gonna go
this way
yes we did gold mass quest line
thank you stratisberg i'm glad you liked
them
oh god i'm dead
we're fine
got you all scared though didn't i
uh
this looked like an ever jail over here
out over this way out over this way
oh this is that uh hidden castle
right
which i don't think we need to do
ah that's what i thought it was okay or
that's what i thought was an uh abergail
at the top of the clips near where you
were
need to go up to the rectangular thing
on the map
this
why
go to the grace where the road splits so
underneath here
okay
mom
[Music]
is there a side of grace down here as
well
or is there an entrance here
south of where i'm at okay
yes we fought worm piss
i'm heading south but i feel like i'm
going way too far now
this looks like something though
[Music]
i feel like that was way too far why are
we here i don't know i don't i don't
remember an entrance over here to
anything could be wrong though
just looking just checking
okay
do we even know what we're looking for
are you guys just directing me in random
like places now
what is that
i mean like over here
no that's like
little gravestones
i might start looking [ __ ] up
over where you fight the dragon it's
like
[Music]
here
i'm gonna start looking [ __ ] up this is
so hard
okay
demi-human queen glee
gillica
gillica
okay
although toe side of grace rox ruins
basement entrance
show me on a map
aha
see
that helps
all right
so it's
yeah
okay
i've been here
very close to it
holy [ __ ] it's so hard to explain things
it's so hard
haven't we done this up here already it
might be i might be wrong about that
i remember you guys telling me to go up
here
[Music]
sky room
[Music]
and let him live for no reason
rick
what are these things
i feel like i've ever seen you
my god so many
[Music]
you're the semi-demi humans
hang it
man they really reuse these guys huh a
lot
okay
look at dead
archery avatar you guys said there is
not an urgery avatar around here right
if i remember
you guys saying that
look up sage's cave
it's actually really close to
here uh okay
[Music]
is this not where i was just looking
[Music]
i don't know why i can't like
memorize [ __ ]
i think it's here
it's in the capitol but you said it
wasn't a boss
oh okay
it's right here
imagine just chilling in your cave and
rick comes and [ __ ] you up
true
are you scared of accidentally doxing
yourself i don't know how that would be
possible of me just having a browser
open but
no
um
yes ratagon is going to get mowed last
we are saving him
for last
i think that's a good way to go about it
right
yep
we killed melania
you're dead
laney is dead as hell
sorry i'm looking at this really quick
why are we saying mode why aren't we
yeah that is godwin's eye right there
look at that
100 an eyeball
am i missing i swear this is where it
told me to be
maybe it meant below me
it's like
oh it's in down in the water
like that
like down there
yeah moog is our new catchphrase
yeah godwin's corpses are everywhere as
facts
he's spreading around
all over the place
you have any plans for the future
where
you do play other
[Music]
other games
i wouldn't say i have plans but
i would be
i would want to do that
i think that's going to be horny
regardless
marinator
right there's no stopping the inevitable
you
die
oh other elden ring players
i don't know
we'll see
two chests right next to each other what
the frick
what the [ __ ]
you look fake
i was right
what the hell
three piece
look at all these chests
uh definitely god when spreading death
neat
i got a three-piece mcnugget
can i get a drink with that please
these [ __ ] be thirsty
whoa
you fake
let me pick it up
oh i need that
no you're hot stan oh i'm dead though
look at all my arrows
what is this cave there's so many chests
holy [ __ ]
couple of dragons
invisible boss is where you need a
sentry torch
rick
can still kill them
or rick can see all
okay
or can you actually not hit it
oh you can
oh you absolutely
[Music]
very cool all right
he did
she
go was this uh sage's grave yeah so
sainted hero's grave now
i spelled heroes wrong range okay
oh that is
okay a little bit south of us
storm collar church
i like that straight road
so
straight road here
and then
it's kind of at the end of it
okay
there's another boss there son of a
[ __ ]
should have been more
should have been more patient i didn't
look at chat while i was doing that
all the way at the end where i was at
yeah damn it
neck romancer garrus
believe me be
it'd go in that cave that's underground
all right stan
do i go this way this time
oh no those are just chess
oh
that's like one of the best armor sets
and yeah that's one of the best armors
in the game right there bro
up here we go
yo what up garrus who the [ __ ] are you
oh [ __ ]
lol
lol
all right garrus is dead okay can i
leave now chat
can i leave this area
we gotta go there
how was he not on this list
oh he is
sorry
that's not a boss
yeah that armor is really good this uh
let's see
raptors black feathers
strengthens jump attacks
rick is now warm
does rick have permission to wear this
chat
i have to start from windmill village
all the way up here
i'm gonna follow it from down here
no
yes
yes
rick was just cold
it kind of looks sick like it kind of
matches
all right i'll do a poll
because you guys are saying a lot of
dumb uh other stuff
and rick where uh coach
asking
we should respect the cosplay all right
all right i mean it still is i think it
still is
[Music]
do some rick rolling
i like that idea
[Music]
ah it's mostly yes
rick is god and can do whatever he wants
that's that's a better way to put it i
think
rick's just a bit chilly
i do look like a part of the night's
watch actually dude
[Laughter]
okay it looks like yes i think it still
goes with it
it kind of matches rick just needed a
little bit of an upgrade that's all
just a little bit
okay let's go around back here
oh you gotta admit it looks pretty cool
on brick huh
i mean like come on it looks pretty damn
killing me
rick is god there is no upgrade
you are speaking true
however
rick is still cold
[Music]
it kind of shows rick's journey in my
opinion
i live in missouri
[Laughter]
do i see someone on the steps of this
definitely
yep i live in misery
[Music]
hmm
yeah it shows character development
oh it's a black knife
let's see how good our jump attacks are
[Music]
dang
what are the lore reasons for wearing
such a coat
rick is cold
oh the black knife
oh [ __ ]
there it is
dagger once belonging to the assassins
who murdered godwin the golden the
knight of black knives a ritual
performed on an oddly misshaped blade
imbued with it the power of the of the
stolen rune of death
ah this tells us what it is that's so
lame
map location
right there
yes ricky is a bit nippy
so he got a jacket
there it is the coat was cold
that's our answer
guys the coat was cold
so rick wanted to warm up the coat
that that is that's the lore right there
[Laughter]
all right does this lead to a boss of
any kind probably let's do it
hello
what a waste
what
shadow baits in light knows weakness
oh is this where you got to pull the
shadows into light
bing ling ling
rick knew this would be fake
that one's bathing in the light
why is this so open
oh i see
come come come come come come
there you go
now you're freaking dead idiot
why does rick think everyone's an idiot
why is rick so angry
rick just went back to where he came
from
rick is upset
there's a chariot i didn't see one
[Music]
lord commander rick
wonder why ronnie chose godwin to murder
maybe because he was the golden
i have a feeling that america didn't
want godwin for whatever reason
i just don't know what that reason is
because there is a ghost that says that
one of america's children was unwanted
it possibly could have been godwin
i'm not sure
is this fake
i know
one of those ghosts said that one of
america's children was unwanted i just
don't know which one of those that is
looks like that's gonna fall through i
just want this item first
there we go
rick was right
wow yeah this dungeon is really cool
so
he keeps falling on it
damn it
yeah he was repeatedly and accidentally
stabbed that's right that's right i'm
not using that there
oh
okay that's where i was
oh i'm back here now okay
because he has no combat abilities
unlike the rest of the demigods i mean
do we know that i don't think so
do we know that godwin had no combat
abilities
the unwanted child was morgot i mean it
said child not children
so that would be morgot and moog if
that's the case
do i need to activate a contraption
dang it
[Music]
no godwin did not have the rune of death
this screams chariot to me
kill it fast kill it fast
who
who designed that
because you're nuts
you are nuts for designing that
absolutely insane
worst enemy in the game
ah
are you the boss
let's get to it
what the [ __ ]
you're not a boss
okay you need to come to light sir
thank god
how do i bring this one to the light
will it drop down
okay good to know
godwin somehow prevented the elden ring
from shattering
how do you know that i don't think
is there anything that says that
no don't walk away
go
i'm back
is it even necessary that i kill this
guy
yes
[Music]
oh
that's different
how do i get there
oh i rode this thing up that's right
oh god
oh it's past the blades
oh [ __ ]
hmm
[Music]
maybe ronnie hated him because he was
blonde
that's a weird reason to hate somebody
but maybe
[Music]
hmm
thought we'd be back here but i guess
you're right
right
we think ronnie's hair was red it would
make sense that it would be red
apparently i need to i need to follow
your directions to a t
because you guys have never been wrong
before right
never been wrong
not once
you can see it's red i mean kind of not
exactly but
i think so
there we go
ah
[Music]
what the music just changed
no frost
philip i don't understand your question
[Music]
all right
so that was zamor
i did this uh this one right
i think so
am i tripping
no i did that was at the beginning right
here
stone digger troll where is that
stone digger troll in altus plateau
ronnie is the red haired champion
alexander eight her body is right above
jarburg he was the power to instantly
kill us he has the power to instantly
befriend us
uh no
what video day was
placido sax fight in
[Music]
oh
um
yesterday right
i think so
yeah one either yesterday or the day
before sorry
when you said video i got confused
but yeah
old altis tunnel
old all this tunnel
is it near altus tunnel
yeah i know kale
yeah he's kidding he's kidding he's
kidding okay
all right where is it in relation to
here
hey you guys gotta be specific i'ma look
it up
i'm over it okay
or a red circle
west of there
a red circle
you can't just say east okay nope
nope
it's gotta be specific
old altis tunnels
i could look that up
there it is
i
the [ __ ]
huh
confusion ensues
[Music]
rick is confused
oh i remember i tried to use my um
i remember
i tried to use my keys
and it didn't work and that's why it's
unlocked but i never went in
you betrayed us i've already done it a
few times okay
you're way behind
i think it would make the most sense
that dlc would go back in time before
all of this happened
but
we'll have to wait and see
i'm going based off the list caleb
[Music]
the list i have i have
horse was happy to see me
godwin as a boss would be neat
i hope we at least see god when before
he was changed into what he is now
i would like that
this wall's fake
nice fire bro
those hammer
this is great i love this
my god
that looks like a stone digger troll to
me
i could have blown it up right there
boom
yo i really did get ganked there huh i
mean sheesh bro
okay
got it
altus plateau
done
last remaining area
is the mountaintops of the giants
black blade kindred death right bird
okay i know where that is
or do i yeah of course
let's go for it let's kill that uh death
right bird i know exactly where it is
and i hate that fight but we gotta do it
huh
we gotta [ __ ] do it dude so that is
poured here and i go down this way right
yeah
i want a one-eyed snake as a boss
so god
one
i think you did black knight kindred
is this a different one here
you know
craft holy water pots
rick cannot use holy water pot
what's your request
really
this fight might actually be hard
yeah definitely hard
definitely hard
i also [ __ ] hate this fight
cool
i'm dead
i don't know why i tried that
that was silly
i don't know
i think that was better
i don't know i don't remember what to do
here oh god
are you kidding
bruh
oh god
i'm gonna die from the flames
it's gonna be close
now it's gonna be really close
a pullback
no
dude you're kidding me
where's his health at
god these birds suck dude they suck
you're kidding me
the these are the worst fights in the
game
god
i have to absolutely be [ __ ] my dick
right there
i 100 used my physics shut the [ __ ] up
you're just wrong
you had you're fizzy
he's got [ __ ] two shots
[Music]
what is
that how many attacks does this thing
have
like are you kidding
now we're doing this
i can't hit it
all right it's a nice quick ass
whoever designed this boss should be
fired
fire the person who made this boss
fire them
did i not stagger you
guess not
gotta go for it
you missed that was like half a [ __ ]
second where his stagger is like the
longest in the game
i love it i did sometimes chat just
[ __ ] said [ __ ] you don't even know
[ __ ] god damn
[Music]
i'm just gonna say words in the chat
even though i'm wrong
[Music]
oh we're doubling up
oh
oh
dude
there's just no way
awful boss
just
terrible
that's right bird dead okay
great worm theatrics
oh wait we killed some more too
didn't we kill black blade kindred
we killed the one in the snow fields
didn't we
actually let me check
you did
that's what i thought i swear we did a
black blade kindred
let me see if we killed this oh wait it
needs to be night time
or does it
or a death right bird
yeah
yeah
base of the waterfall in the consecrated
snow fields
face of the waterfall
uh
maybe right here
god not again
yeah
oh i was immediately running and i still
got hit thank you
[ __ ] you
please be dead thank you wow that was
perfect almost nice
that wasn't even on our list so we did
it
it's a 220 000 rune one
nice
thank god we got that out of the way
what what am i hearing over here
can you talk now
i sit in your lap
can i kill you
okay
this magma worm has mid-year levels of
damage negation oh [ __ ] base of the
waterfall
at the east end of the snow field has
theatrics
uh
i don't know where the waterfall is
is it like
oh that's
snow fields
this is probably the waterfall right
here right so
go there
um i'll just start from here
yeah i know they're part of uh the quest
line
real true true or uh
what is that big
lieutenant that albanoric's name do we
know her name
congrats on 65k
love your content and keep up the good
work devilish face your mental health
video is very inspiring and i wish you
all the best in life insert many pets
for joy smiling faces
that's very nice thank you man did we
reach 65k
oh we did oh [ __ ]
nice guys
and thank you dude i i appreciate the
donation for the super chat thank you
and the kind words i didn't know we got
that
sweet
let's go good [ __ ] guys
we're on our road to 100k
or 69k i guess first
why don't you ever block
with a sword
doesn't really do anything
but thank you esther i appreciate you
very much
uh oh
all right
it's not bad damage for a body shot
or yeah it is
oh god
okay
what okay
not what i wanted to do there that's
okay
this one's a way bigger
for sure
holy [ __ ] that's a lot of damage
this one's huge
ah that's why i put that on
never mind he's gonna keep spamming it i
guess oh god
can i reach its head
that's such [ __ ]
that's such dog [ __ ] okay
let's put lava right next to his uh his
spot here
dodging that is so [ __ ] hard
come on
let me get one shot here i know it
i'm spamming
first try
that thing has a ton of health oh my god
okay good [ __ ] good [ __ ] good [ __ ]
um
great worm theatrics
got it
okay we killed black knight kindred
our last boss the misbegotten crusader
where is that
our last boss before radagon and the
elden beast we are almost done
i i don't know conan what arm are you
currently wearing
raptors black feathers
it does more jump attack damage
the dungeon right next to you
you need two
stone sword keys
we have
one um okay it was easy to get over here
so it's still in this area right here
let me let me unlock it first
i don't see a cave
is it up there
or am i overthinking it
okay giant squid
pave okay i can't unlock it
um pretty easy to get back here though
so let's go here
yeah i should i should check the
merchant shops yep
no we're still rick
rick
thought that this coat was cold
so uh yeah
okay zero
none
none
guys are you sure
that um
when you go to this main menu here
purchase it doesn't show you everything
i'm
very certain it does but you guys were
really adamant that it doesn't
sullivas
or win these ball bearing
yeah it def it definitely does when you
go to this purchase
none
literally says all items yeah it does
okay um where else can i get one
didn't you guys say a merchant in the
snow fields somewhere
we're on our last boss the misbegotten
crusader
whatever
it doesn't though i mean i just saw it
it doesn't it does
it does show you everything
we just looked at it how could you get
like
i swear to god some of you just say [ __ ]
do it in the comments of the youtube
video and in the live streams
all items
tools
stone sword keys
from each bell bearing
well i guess yeah if you have to go like
this obviously to see everything but
yeah when it came to the items that we
wanted
yes
okay
decent spirit nomadic merchant at
castlemorn
so here
yeah i saw we get a ratagon's
sword from that crusader
i already bought these unfortunately
hmm
okay you guys are just all saying [ __ ]
whatever
i mean we just [ __ ] saw it but you
can keep saying whatever you want i'll
go check this one
i do have one key
i need two though
unusually this aged merchant have
something that caught
back already okay there's three here
thanks man
i only needed one more but
let's buy them all [ __ ] it dude
okay
so that's oslo
cave of the forelorn huh
have you tried simply just having enough
keys
i guess so
you viking jack you sound like such a
[ __ ] dick dude shut the [ __ ] up holy
[ __ ]
don't get mad at me what are you [ __ ]
12.
it needs no keys
i don't know i just heard someone in
chat say you need to
but let's go up here and say let's see
if we're just saying [ __ ]
which was my whole [ __ ] point
hey look you need two keys
one
two
but i guess we needed no keys
that's my point sometimes people just
say [ __ ] maybe they're saying it wrong i
don't know they typed it wrong
i can't tell that though
actually a cool dragon right here
702 701
i can lash out at whoever i want if
you're being stupid in the chat i will
call you out on it
maybe just don't be [ __ ] stupid and i
won't call you out on it it's that
simple let's blame it all on the
streamer
right
typical dumbass viewer
typical one percent of chat
the rest of chat's always great then
there's that one person who thinks they
don't think that this is my stream and
it's theirs [ __ ] dumbass
damn that guy a lot of health
this is cool though
you can see down below
imagine you break that though
now now he's just sounding off as i
called him out
nicholas lillies
wonder why those are here
it's not a toxic chat just one person in
chat being
toxic right now
oh
oh like a little kid he's just gonna go
lmao
it's shy
i like looking down here looks cool
did you know how i know you're like a
young guy
is because
whenever you're called out on something
instead of like making points you'll
just go lmao
so many kids [ __ ] do that dude
this is so funny to me this is so
funny
that people are calling out my toxicity
lol
lmao
yeah and i read those points and then i
called you stupid because they were
stupid
hmm
must have
something how the heck do i get down
there
no you're just saying i'm contradicting
myself which doesn't make what i said
contradictory just because you said that
i don't even think you know what the
definition is because i haven't been
contradictory in the slightest
yeah i gotta climb up some copper rock
i can hear stuff over there
this is so funny lmao
those are not nice jellyfish
nothing that way though
i mean i could have banned you a long
time ago but i've given you like
10 minutes to just apologize
but i don't
probably not gonna do that are you
i don't know why the jellies are angry
they are angry here
because they're stuck
okay so probably not a good way to
apologize is that that way
nice apology i have nothing to apologize
for this is my stream
[Music]
i wonder why he has ratagon sword
wow
wow that's a lot of damage
hi stan
did i not pick the uh no i did i went i
walked the wrong way did it oh i see i
see
i see i see
okay well um stan can you ban
what's his name what's his name chat
i don't even know um
jack something
ban him because now he's just getting
attention from everybody i shouldn't
have even given him that much attention
that's exactly what he wants
so just get rid of him
viking jack that's it
look what he said he said lmao
told you
thank you stan
this
is a lot of damage
we maybe
he doesn't let you heal either
wow
[Music]
okay obviously ban witch king too
jesus christ
a lot of attention seekers right now
just get rid of them i'm over it
thank you
oh you can say lmao just like when
you're having an argument with i've just
noticed this especially when i stream
for um
for four years
on twitch where i was playing a game
that was mainly meant for children
like rocket league
i had a lot of young guys in my chat
like a lot of young kids and i swear to
god every time they would like have an
argument with me the only thing they
would say is lmao to absolutely
everything
they wouldn't argue they'd just say no
you're wrong lmao
no you're being contradictory lmao
it wouldn't actually like make a point
about anything
but they think they are though
there we go
you should engage with toxic commenters
um
no i'll engage with them i'll give them
a chance to either apologize or like
make their point
any anyone who says like just don't talk
to people like that
they've never been a streamer before
i've been doing this a long time i know
exactly how it works
people people like that do not get to me
in any sort of fashion i will completely
forget about this interaction in about
20 minutes
do not worry about it
that's it everyone
that's literally everything
the entire list has been checked all
except
for radagon
and the elden beast
we are down
to the end
no we gotta do after the final boss
it's time guys
it's time to bring it home
was this 12 days
day 12.
we're finally here we have done
absolutely everything that we can do
oh yes well no we could we could remove
the frenzied flame after ratagon that is
still an option
you absolutely can
you can remove it you can um
you can leave after you beat ratagon and
the elden beast
unless i'm wrong
i that's what i thought but
is that not true
take off the bird part okay i'll put our
armor back on
the full kid is back
you go straight into the cutscene no you
don't you have to touch the elden ring
to do that
we can decide now though what ending do
we want we should decide that now let's
decide that
um either way
it doesn't matter
so let's what ending should we have as
options i can only have four so
lame of frenzy
oh [ __ ] we got wait we're not done guys
never mind we can't go do this yet
we need to go turn in all our death
route we need to go turn in
i pre-jacked it oh no i pre-jacked
prejected man oh [ __ ] i'm glad we just
got that because i was gonna forget
let's go see how much more death route
we need to turn in for one
and then uh also the stuff we need for
the dong eater too
one
i won't
forget
again
my appetite
my sin
i must have more
i must consume
more
okay i don't know how how do i know how
much i've turned in
feet
hmm
yeah i totally forgot about this too
let's go check the dung eater as well
the dung
eater
i don't like being edged like that i'm
sorry i'm sorry
ah [ __ ]
we gotta do it though we have to
yeah yeah we know that we can remove it
they were just
um wondering if we had to remove it
before we go into the radagon fight i'm
like 99 sure that we can do the ratagon
eldenbees fight and then can leave take
out the flame of frenzy and then have
all the under any other endings if we
want to
this is this wall zile handers i'll
wall hander
however you say it
i've already turned in a bunch of death
route
before that one
i just don't know how many more we need
golden order
one day
you'll get what's coming
it automatically does oh it does
really
okay well then we'll decide before we go
in okay
we'll decide before we go in
yeah because i i don't remember
if it does happen right after we beat
him or that we have to touch the elden
ring
i actually don't know that
okay
he gets nine in total um
where do we get seed bed curses chad
let's let's focus let's do let's do dong
eater where do we get all the seed bed
curses
i guess i can look that up let me start
looking [ __ ] up cause that's this is
getting
see sea bed is it sea bed
seabed
the seed bed seed bed
where to find sea bed lay in del roy
capital after you exit the room in
australia to the south
and this is tough
i'm trying to reach yet
let's focus on this so it looks like
there's six
one two three four five six so
from the prayer room head forward going
down the staircase to come across trump
down head toward the room two cleaner
knights inside but instead of entering
jump over the railing of the right and
drop down one level
turn around enter a dark room on the
railing
it will eagle you proceed until you
reach the teleporter to right card
then go back into the building and
upstairs to find a fog door that
requires a stone sword key okay i know
where that is let's
at least do that
let's at least do that
that is
okay
[Music]
okay
believe those are the last two things we
need to do death root and seed bed curse
and then we can fight ratagon
i just don't know how many we've turned
in i kind of wish you could tell
thank you chat
thank you metal
oh then i have five hours okay okay you
got this
so yeah here's the thing i don't
remember it's been 12 days of us doing
everything in the game and i don't
remember
how many we've turned in and stuff like
that
this has been a
disorganized mess trying to be as
organized as possible so it is what it
is
metal is quite hot
it is true
nice that felt good i like that
you turn the seed bed curses into the
dung eater
when he's tied to his chair
but think about what ending you want
chat because we will once we do both of
these things we're going to put it to a
vote
think about what ending you want
go up here
turn around
go this way
um here we go
okay
then it's somewhere in here
i think it's that
how do i get over there
oh well let's go down for now
actually i think it's down here
it's that
all right
there's one boys
that is a really good picture of right
card
trying to get out of
here okay
i've turned in five
no shot
okay let's look up another one
so
that was volcano manor check it off
check it out
the body of the black guard at the end
of this questline we did that in the
alternate version of the round table
loaded near the fortified
near the fortified manor grace inside
the equivalent of the dung eaters room
you can find it on a body i'm pretty
sure we did that i'm actually 100
certain we did that
um
the halogen tree from the prayer room
grace
so let's do that
in the prayer room
okay
oh what b seal incantations you have if
you show me okay i'll let me let me try
and show that
would it be easier to do here
like a spell
um
i think it's all these ones on the
bottom right
yeah we'll double check
need five
i mean this is for death root
let's uh let's do this one let's focus
so
from prayer room
keep heading forwards going down every
staircase you come across
drop down and head toward the room with
two clean rod knights inside
but instead of entering jump over the
railing to the right and drop down one
level
turn around enter the dark room right
under the railing and you will find it
on a body that is sitting in a chair
go down all the stairs
that we see
stairs
at five turn any four more okay thank
you
there's
stairs
appears you can't teleport after beating
elden beast not sure if that's new okay
um we'll still decide before we go fight
i think that would be cooler if we know
what we want before we go in right
that would be cooler
okay so they said
here's the two clean rot nights
we're going to go on a railing
jump down
that's not what we wanted
whoops
i thought that was a railing bro i
didn't see it was
curved [ __ ]
it means he didn't kill all of the
bosses i guess not that's true
i wonder if they count as bosses though
that could be the other part where we
get death root from do all of them count
as bosses
just think of what ending you want chat
we will get there
pretty soon
this game's [ __ ] long
so
railing
is just that thing right there
should just kill them but
probably this
all right
on every staircase drop down head
towards the room to come out and instead
inside but instead of entering jump over
the railing to the right and jump down
one level turn around enter the dark
room right under the railing you will
find
okay
it was before this
dark room right here
there's a bunch of crystallines in here
[ __ ]
earth see bed
not that
yeah i don't think it's this room
i think it's another room
anything but you
i need to run
like we aren't beating these
there's two
that's over here
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
it's in that room but upstairs
[ __ ]
dang
it that there's three
that's a no-go zone
gotta zip back to the grace go down the
stairs just before the room with the
knights there's a railing to the right
okay before the room it did say that
dang it
i'm dyslexic
flapped i would like to see quite
literally anybody in the world survive
that
okay really got it
this makes sense
god damn
oh god
all right there it is
got it
okay
done
done oh wait this is a different one
from the prayer room grace head toward
forwards until the end of stairs with
two cross crossbow men above you
jump on the arch to the right and hop
onto the platform to the left with the
crimson teardrop scarab
okay let's just start with that
okay we got it
progress is being made guys we're doing
it
i think the naomi's way behind
okay so i'm going forward until i see
two crossbow dudes
are these guys crossbow dudes
yup
what'd it say after that
two crossbow dudes um jump on the arch
to the right and hop on a platform
to the left jesus
[Music]
ah okay so down there
so here
to here
that guy was [ __ ] blind as [ __ ]
[Music]
okay
sorry i'm just kind of checking hey it's
finley cool
i don't think i've ever gotten her ashes
before okay
so
all right
uh to the left should be a cleaner night
with the chest containing finlay hop
onto the arch to the northwest and
follow it up to the balcony
ball the balcony to its end and the item
could be found in a body sitting in a
chair
okay
bro i already forgot
dog you're underground there we go
what the [ __ ]
dude i already forgot what it said like
this is how dyslexic i am
okay queen run hop onto the arch in the
west balcony
it's like right here
okay
the random chest
there it is
man
dung eater was busy here huh [ __ ] okay
we got it
so
let's see
alternate version done black guard done
volcano manor okay so this one would be
the only one we may not have
but let's go to the dung eater and see
because i think we did do that
let's go
that didn't take too long
royal revenants are the physical
manifestation of miyazaki's feet
obsession
i don't know really what real revenants
are but the fact that they exist is a
strong argument for burning it all away
i agree
i think i've already turned in
one
to the dung eater which is why i don't
know how many i have
but we just got
four or three
[Music]
hello dong eater
curse you golden order
one day
you'll get what's coming
[Music]
use the seed bed curse
oh [ __ ] we did it
okay we had them all
or maybe not
[Applause]
[Music]
damn
gross
there it is
receive the mending rune
mending rune of the fel curse
let's read it
low some rune
sated from the dunk by the dung eater
yesterday
used to restore the fractured elven ring
when branched by the elden lord the
reviled curse will last eternally and
the world's children grandchildren in
every generation hence
will be its pustles
in order to
if order is defiled entirely defilement
is defilement no more and for every
curse a cursed blessing
gross okay
um god damn alright so
death root
is our last thing we need
so let's look at death root
death root
then i was called
am i tripping
there it is i was scrolled up too far
so obtained
found in the chest beside black knight
assassin death how do i not have all of
them if i've done all of this stuff
can be found inside a chest defeating
the stray mimic tear
in the secret catacomb underneath the
halet pat hidden path to the halo tree
oh
in the secret catacombs
do you guys know where that is
[Music]
hmm
yeah i probably missed some chess
okay
so back here somewhere
oh that's why it says beast eye quivers
in here huh okay
shut up stan
is it the one where i dropped
this is not fair this is just stupid
is it this this jump right here
what the [ __ ] dude
jesus
yes okay
what
they're so short
okay what's uh what's the way to do this
someone said there's an invisible floor
is that that true
[Music]
yep
that is true
silver scarab
is there still a secret floor
whoa
yo
i'm scared
rainbow stones
no shot this goes straight right
okay just go straight
oh i'm dead
what the [ __ ]
the hell is that dude
i there is some weird like unbalanced
difficulty in this game
at certain points dude there really is
it just comes out of [ __ ] nowhere
there's no benz easy to figure out the
path
so
oh
oh okay
there we go i thought i [ __ ] up
please
dante ow
it's a sacramental bud
okay can i can i just go straight here
like if i line myself up with the door
okay
okay
[Music]
okay
well this guy's confident in where he is
no you are not hiding that card
[Music]
death root
okay
now what do i do here
pulling the lever and i'm running
oh boys
one voice
get we definitely didn't do every boss
then that list is balls
unless we don't need to
is there no boss meter
it's me
it's rick
oh no
this is the true final boss
rick b rick
let's make it a three-way
[Music]
[Music]
he looks so strong
[Music]
i can feel the universe imploding on
itself
balance has been restored
cool
all right
got it
death root
obtained okay there's so much power in
one room it really there really truly is
secretary of shade probably found that
we've done every tibia red wolf champion
we did we did the stray mimic
giants mountaintop catacombs this is
what somebody in chat was talking about
earlier giants mountaintop catacombs
that's what he was talking about
which we have not found where is that
that list is a little bit off
there can only be one
is it um
it's near the grand lift of rolled
so
here
let's go talk to shibriri
you didn't tibia before death bird
in mountaintops
there's a tibia here
up shabiri's dead
nice
okay so gotcha man
you're saying i need to go before
why do we need to go back to the dungeon
what the [ __ ]
passes more ruins
you get to fire people
it's behind you at the bottom of the
hill to be in your castle soul okay like
okay
focus on the
on this
what's okay we can do that because i
don't know where this is right now so
the fire people are up here
got it
and get your sword back in limb grave
cool
cool
if you go to the dung eater you'll get
his gear
okay that would be cool
for sure
would you say before the fire people
northeast of the ruins
is it like to the left over there
like back here
there it is
jesus dude that list is off
okay we're finding it all
thank you
got it
the beast i quivers
the b cycles
anything but the
amps [ __ ]
i hate you
i hate you
i love you
yeah we're in the mountaintops
holy [ __ ]
goddamn
worst dungeon in the game
oh
god
fall down here i dare you bro
oh little pop boys
i'm gonna be attacked
alexander
elevator is long bro
that was different
i mean we are kind of speed running oh
my god
jesus
it's another maze one son of a [ __ ]
you they're all farting gross bro
a little ritual pot aight
you're so short
i love you
okay
wait
no i told him i loved him before i
killed him it's fine
okay
check all the elevators
why i'm looking looking what am i
looking for what am i looking for
stop it
please
i don't want to hurt you
okay i'm just going to continue on
because i didn't i don't know if i
should go back up the elevator or not
i'm confused
not again
what the [ __ ]
okay
dang it
how many times do i gotta go in a circle
man
oh boys go
what the
i'm running
he's so big
i thought it would hit him
boom boom boom
that's what she said good job chad good
job
oh my
i'm tripping out i'm tripping
i'm tripping
tripping balls you could say dripping
balls oh
ah
goodbye my friend
goodbye
okay we got another one
aha
there you are you little forehead
you little forehead goober
go back up
yes
rick succumbed to the loop
but rick defeated the loop as well
or rick
is very strong
let's continue
please don't be one of those oh
my god
[ __ ]
we'll take the hit
where am i
mommy
mommy oh
it hurts
i don't want to die
rick was never scared
rick doesn't get scared
we fought melania
two days ago
[Music]
okay you said there was a tibia mariner
that i have not fought up here as well
i don't know if haskell i really don't
i have no idea
maybe it was just like
bosses that didn't involve death root or
whatever
who knows
there could have been like specifics
uh oh my game crashed
i think my game crashed
no
no please
elden ring
please
i think it crashed
oh wait it works
so it didn't crash
ah
it's just loading
wait what
ex what
so what do i do just wait
i'm confused
you've had that before it's just gonna
be stuck here all right what do i do for
great entertainment
you're welcome man
and thank you for the super chat i
appreciate that
dude am i gonna lose my save
wait what do i do
i'm
i'm so scared
restart you're fine
okay
do i just end it like this
you're fine lose all of that progress
oh god okay so
stop
confirm
okay
really strange
what
when when
when when
it saves i
i mean [ __ ]
i really don't want to do this again i
ain't gonna cap
this is taking a long time to start as
well
imagine losing all your progress i think
i would be upset
rick is too strong
we beat that boss so bad that the game
didn't know what to do
rick quite literally
came out of the game and broke it see
uh oh
okay rick
rick
do we have death root
two death root acquired
okay we're fine
everything's fine
it's okay chad
everyone
breathe
okay where'd you say it was
the tibia
tibia murder marinara sauce
to be a mariner
but tim thank you again for the super
chat i really do appreciate that thank
you
oh thank god
to be a marinara sauce i guess i could
look it up you said it was in the
mountaintops of the giants so
castle soul main gate
on a ledge between the castle main gate
and the snowy valley snow valley ruins
overlook
take a look at where that is
right there
so
okay
got it
understood fam understood it's like
right here
tibia marinara sauce
[Music]
yeah it's near the tip of the peepee
the peace dyke quiver
there you are
ow
my hot bod
whoa
i need to be a little bit more careful
yo that boat lit
tibia alfredo sauce
the boats get stuck
she dead
that was a
helping steel
yeah you stupid snail
yeah no boss bar there
um
let's go turn them in boys i don't know
how many more we need
because i feel like we have every other
one turned in
uh but let's go find out
hey greg
we got some death root for you
three
my thanks
tarnished you're welcome
death
my sin
should not be touched
by the hand of man
i shall grant thee
my claws
feed me
oh there's one more isn't there
wow that's all really cool
feed
though
there's one more
no way no that's grank not malacath um
[ __ ]
okay
so
black knife assassin
death touch catacombs we definitely did
that cemetery shade
in the black knife catacombs we
definitely did that
summer water village definitely windham
ruins definitely east lurinia of the
lakes definitely castle means soul
definitely
red wolf 100
boom and then
what are we missing
i feel like we've done all of them
trying to think
might have missed have missed chest
after boss fight okay um well let's go i
mean i doubt that bro i really do black
knife catacombs
so that's
a top up way up there okay
so that's
over
here always go check
i may have missed a chest but i'm pretty
sure is one more
nah he said feed me more
all right
y'all can yell at me now
everyone
say
jake
you're cute
call guys good call
just [ __ ] missed it i guess
thanks guys it is
it is all
consumed
still
i am not sated
not nearly sated
oh he's gonna [ __ ] me up huh america
is this
what it is
to sing
will things
never be the same
again
america [ __ ] this guy up
my thanks
for thy long
labor
but i have done
all i
can in this land
henceforth
mine appetite
shall be my soul companion
farewell
there it is boys
all right
there you go
we did it
we freaking did it
it's happening
we're doing the thing
i want to see if we can see him howling
out here it or he's just completely gone
so he gone
is he not over here
sometimes you can see him howling over
here
i infamous
nah he gone all right
chat it is time to decide the ending
that we all want i hope you all know
what ending you want
i'm gonna do the more popular ones
because i don't think we can do uh more
than four options
what
ending
so we'll do
just elden lord ending
ronnie ending
lame of frenzy
and
dung
dung eater
i don't think anyone's gonna pick golden
order
or like yeah gold mask
you decide boys and girls you decide
that no one wants the normal elden lord
get the dung eater armor i'm gonna use
this armor i'm not super worried about
it
is the flame of frenzy going to win
really
really
oh it's changing i'm gonna let it go for
a while i really am
stan
oh man i'm excited guys i really am
i'm [ __ ] excited dude this is it
we've been doing this for weeks bro
i should point this out really quick too
let's check this really quick
we're gonna go to my youtube channel
let's go
let's go here
and go to our uploads
we
started this
i tried doing it a while back and and
decided not to i wanted to do another
way this was day one
we were at
38 000 subscribers
38 000.
and now we're just hit 65 000
subscribers that's huge bro
that's huge so thank you very much i
appreciate every single one of you
and it looks like we're letting chaos
take the world baby
all right
flame of frenzy it is then
let's do it
this is it
the end game
let's do it
hopefully it doesn't start right away
pascal but we'll see
there she is
i really wonder why they look decayed
do you think it's when the elden ring
shattered that this is what happened to
their like body
there it is
this music's so good
yeah they look like stone
rick is ready
to end this
now
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
man i went all the way around
[Music]
that's annoying
what
oh my man's just going off right now
[Music]
damn
he was going a little crazy there [ __ ]
damn
that was a pretty good first attempt no
cap
no mimic
either
i pop it out
shut up stand
get him rick
[Music]
now
okay
rick no
now
how do you dodge that attack
i don't get it
bro these aoe attacks are so [ __ ]
insane
bro lay off man
dude
rick's
dead ratagon's dead now
that's good we have a chance
we've got a chance
you gotta jump on the last one really
[Music]
time for space dog
it's ludex gundyr
[Music]
the music is a 10 out of 10.
[Music]
look at [ __ ] rick dude
oh rick let's get it buddy
other rick is dead
we gotta pop off
elven booty time
thanks for the five bucks man i
appreciate that
thank you
[Music]
son of a [ __ ]
rick shall take the throne
let chaos take the world
howie
i [ __ ] up really bad oh god
my audio bug there i don't know if you
guys heard that but it really distracted
me and i'm making excuses right now for
my bad dodge
all right all right we can do better in
the first phase anyway
papa rune
i ain't got no runes
i panicked dodged twice for dog
panic twice
panic panic panic dot panic panic i
panicked
all right we got this should have thrown
the axe
if sun was in my eyes a lot a lot going
on there
great start
i wasn't panicking you were
[Music]
i don't know if he can jump that someone
said jump it
i don't know
oh rick's done for
rip rick
rick stop standing in it you stupid
idiot
rick
[Music]
i mean it's sipping right now
full radagon mode
yeah that's not bad that's not bad at
all okay we're good we're looking great
right now
good [ __ ] let's go let's get it
do not run from me you peasant
well at least it didn't go for other
rick because i think he would have insta
died right there
okay
what okay
i really wish you could use torrent in
this i think it would make the fight so
much better if you could use torrent
bricks almost dead
i think rick's dead
oh it's me oh they split
how was he not dead
knew it he tried to trick me by going
for other rick
bro that delay is quite quite long quite
long
really
we are getting
awful rng right now
like i said
little do you know rick likes torture
he enjoyed that
are you kidding that i'm almost dead
from that oh
[ __ ]
so
i
do not understand what they were
thinking when they designed that attack
no idea
but that was that was awful rng
terrible rng through that entire thing
he did elden sharks
and then
at the same time
uh doing his
flame things where he's throwing him at
me or whatever i'm gonna wait to use
rick
why i'm going for a hit there
nice
yes i'm making excuses
let me make them
[Music]
no i got distracted by rick no
no
rick
finish him rick
get him
god
that was my fault
i for some reason while he was loading
that up i just stared at rick no idea
why
damn coming out live
did you know that in the making of
soldier of gothic they had to nerf him
due to the fact he was gaining sentience
sections
what does that mean
thanks for the super chat i appreciate
you thank you
good [ __ ] other rick
oh that delayed swing
you can smell it bro i can smell it
hmm okay
[Music]
get over here other rick
finish him
nice
good stuff good stuff
[Music]
good stuff
get that stamina back up
rick split this with me
don't walk into it
good start
good start
okay little ring action
rick stand over here come over here rick
ah [ __ ]
rick's confused
give me the ring man
oh
what the [ __ ] that was weird
get him wrecked
that's it
baby i'm gonna get his ass
we staggered the elden beast
holy [ __ ]
we are gods
this is it
that's a triple ring
huh
why we use that one more hit
wait
we actually did it yes
yes
we did it oh my god we annihilated him
oh i wanted to dab
very nice
there it is
we [ __ ] did it man
see you can leave chat
i told you
i'm leveling for no reason
ah yes
may chaos take the world
hold on i gotta record this
absolutely have to record this
oh yes obvious oops oops opus yes
yes
okay
please don't brick thank you all right
this is it chat
it is time for chaos
become the lord of frenzied flame
soldier of god
rick
[Music]
nice
burn it all
burn it all down
fade away into nothing
yes
it's rick
yes
oh
it's wrecked
may chaos take the world
soldier of god lord of chaos rick
burn it all down
burn it all down
yes
yes
make chaos take the world under rick
it's rick's world now
it's rick's world now
yes
[Music]
holy [ __ ] we actually did it man
we played the entirety of the damn game
oh my controller dc'd that's not that's
not
oh yes
melina wishes to fight rick
but she'll lose
the glormid queen
lord or frenzied flame
i will seek you
as far as you may travel
yes should deliver you what is yours
destined death
little do you know i like destin death
i want it
i created it
laps in the chat boys
flaps in the chat
we did it
we played pretty much
every little bit of this game
[Music]
we'll have to check our hours
it took a lot
and we all kind of knew where we were
going so
we did it
claps in the chat thank you all very
much
[Music]
it's over
the 100 completionist series is over we
[ __ ] did it dude
thanks for being here guys thanks for
the support no i appreciate every single
one of you you're all great i've been
having so much fun streaming on youtube
it's been absolutely awesome
so thank you
hope you liked it hope it was
entertaining seems like it was but
never know
so thank you guys
[Music]
more money for the frenzied flame gustav
thank you man
[Music]
thank you bro for the 20. i really
appreciate you dude thank you so much
thank you guys
let's check our hours
let's go see
so no
let's see how long it took
that was an awesome playthrough that was
really cool
43 hours
in 34 minutes
43 hours
streaming this game
not bad
i see
no dialogue huh
dab dab with me rodericka
dab
this is how we wake every morning under
the reign of rick
we dab on them haters anyway
not bad
guys
i'm gonna go eat because i'm starving
thank you for being here again i
appreciate you thank you so
much look out for two new videos coming
out soon
and we've got a really big sponsor
coming soon as well
uh it's gonna be our first sponsor on
the channel like our first official
sponsor so whenever you see that in one
of the future videos
i'd appreciate the help with that i'd
really really appreciate it ludwig thank
you bro
thanks for the super chat
thank you
get good exactly
um but yeah i'm really excited for that
so look out for that um got two videos
coming out this week
so yeah just look out for that thank you
all so much we will be streaming more i
just don't know what we'll figure it out
i'll ask you guys in the community tab
and see what we do so
guys
i'm out of here
one last t-pose
have a great rest of your day and i will
see you all again very soon
oh my obs ran out of out of storage
perfect at perfect timing awesome
thank you all
and i will see you soon
peace out guys
bye bye bye thanks all thank you all
again you're great
peace